Hey guys, it's Joel, and this is the Taproot Therapy Podcast. We've got a great interview today with Dr. Lawrence Hellman. He's an astrologer and an archetypal researcher who does a lot of work with businesses for coaching and consulting and helping people get to know the different parts of their psyche that lets them be able to create and express themselves fully professionally and personally. So that's interesting. We're going to roll that in just a minute. A couple things coming up with the show. I mean, one, these episodes are probably going to get a lot less regular,
大家好，我是Joel，这里是Taproot Therapy播客。今天我们邀请到了Lawrence Hellman博士进行了一场精彩的访谈。他是一位占星家和原型研究员，在商业教练和咨询领域做了大量工作，帮助人们了解自己心理的不同层面，从而使他们能够在职业和个人生活中充分地创造和表达自我。这非常有趣。我们马上就要开始这段访谈了。关于节目有几件事要说。首先，这些剧集的更新频率可能会降低，
or maybe not. We would really like to have an in-person studio in Birmingham and prioritize in-person episodes soon. The money's not there to do that addition just yet, but hopefully by the end of next year. And then also now that Alice is getting started, hopefully her and then one of our new therapists, James Waits, can be on the show more often as time allows. But this is kind of one of three things pulling me in a couple
或者也可能不会。我们非常希望能在伯明翰拥有一个线下工作室，并尽快优先录制线下节目。目前还没有足够的资金进行扩建，但希望明年年底前能实现。另外，既然Alice已经开始了工作，希望随着时间的推移，她和我们的一位新治疗师James Waits能更频繁地出现在节目中。但这只是让我分心的三件事之一，
directions, and I'm trying to decide how much time I can devote to it. We also have kind of a new technique at Taproot, a new brain-based medicine thing that's exciting and not'm trying to decide how much time I can devote to it. We also have kind of a new technique at Taproot, a new brain-based medicine thing that's exciting and not really ready to be unveiled completely yet, but that is going to take a certain amount of work to develop. If you are a listener to this show and you like it and you want to see more of a certain kind of episode or you want to see more of a certain kind of thing,
我正试图决定能投入多少时间。我们在Taproot还有一种新的技术，一种令人兴奋的基于大脑的医学疗法，虽然还没有完全准备好公开，但开发它需要一定的工作量。如果你是这个节目的听众，你喜欢它，并且希望看到更多特定类型的节目或内容，
now would be the time to reach out because I'm going to be doing my, you know, six months to seven months out planning for guests and, uh, you know, essays that I want to write and do, uh, and may take a little bit of a break. Uh, but if you want to send me an email, um, that's on our website, get therapy, birmingham.com, uh, Joel Blackstock at get therapy, birmingham.com. But you can also see that on my bio page, uh, to give me feedback for the show. That'd be great. Uh, I know that there are some people who listen to it and a couple of you have reached out already who like it. And, um, now would be the
现在就是联系我的好时机，因为我即将开始规划未来六到七个月的嘉宾，以及我想写和做的文章，我可能会稍微休息一下。如果你想给我发邮件，可以在我们的网站gettherapybirmingham.com上找到，或者发送至Joel Blackstock at gettherapybirmingham.com。你也可以在我的个人简介页面上看到这些信息，给我提供节目反馈。那会很棒。我知道有一些人在听，也有几位已经联系过我并表示喜欢这个节目。现在就是
time to do that. Cause that's what I'm going to be working on over the next month. So I'm gonna go ahead and roll that interview. Um, again, this is Dr. Lawrence Selman, and I encourage you to check out the show notes and look at his website and some of his other work because a lot of it's, and he's done so much work, more than I'm probably going to be able to get to. I have a lot of questions, but I'd kind of like to have more of a conversation and just see where things go to. And something about the spontaneity seems to be a little bit more authentic and go a little bit deeper. So I don't want to introduce you too much, but one of my favorite things about your work is that whenever I've come across it, a lot of people who say archetypal or talking about archetypal stuff, because I was familiar with your dad's work with archetypal psychology too,
做这件事的时候了，因为这就是我下个月要忙的事情。所以，我要开始播放那段访谈了。再次说明，这是Lawrence Selman博士，我鼓励大家查看节目说明，浏览他的网站和他的一些其他作品，因为他做了太多工作，可能比我能涉及到的还要多。我有很多问题，但我更想进行一场对话，看看事情会如何发展。某种自发性似乎更真实，也更深入。所以我不想过多地介绍你，但我最喜欢你工作的一点是，每当我接触到它时，很多谈论原型或原型事物的人——因为我也熟悉你父亲在原型心理学方面的工作，
and a lot of the stuff that's coming out of Pacifica in the past couple of years. But a lot of this stuff gets kind of water of Pacifica in the past couple years um and but a lot of this stuff gets kind of watered down when you when you encounter it to where people are really kind of talking about a cultural layer or their political bias or their you know you can just kind of see that what they're talking about is not really um an archetypal energy or really deep timeless thing and you sort of sift through um the the culture to find the stuff that is really perennial, really deep, you know, a samurai and a knight look very different, but what is the thing that is similar in these energies in a way that's very honest and effective? And I don't see a ton of
以及过去几年从Pacifica（太平洋研究院）传出的很多东西——但很多东西在接触时被稀释了，人们实际上是在谈论文化层面、政治偏见，或者你可以看出他们谈论的并不是真正的原型能量或真正深刻、永恒的东西。你会在文化中筛选出那些真正永恒、真正深刻的东西。你知道，武士和骑士看起来非常不同，但这些能量中相似的东西是什么？这是一种非常诚实且有效的方式。我并没有看到太多
that. So I don't know if you agree with that or if that's, I'll leave it there and then hand it over to you. Thank you so much for having me, Joel. And I do, of course, appreciate that's a compliment. Yeah, I think I'm very practical. I'm a hands-on kind of a person and I do coaching and leadership development and this kind of work that needs for me to be really practical things that people can do to better their lives or to you know make more sense of the things that don't make sense to them and archetypes are just a really good tool it's a way of seeing I think of archetypes as wearing a certain set of glasses maybe you remember in the movie National Treasure where Nick Cage is stealing the Declaration of Independence and he needs to find these glasses that Ben Franklin hid forth in a certain way and gets the right combination
这样的内容。所以我不知道你是否同意这一点，或者，我就说到这里，然后交给你。非常感谢你邀请我，Joel。当然，我很感激，这是一种赞美。是的，我认为我非常务实。我是一个亲力亲为的人，我做教练和领导力发展，这种工作需要我提供非常实用的东西，让人们能够改善生活，或者理解那些对他们来说说不通的事情。原型是一个非常好的工具，它是一种观察方式。我把原型看作是戴上一副特定的眼镜。也许你还记得电影《国家宝藏》中，尼古拉斯·凯奇正在偷《独立宣言》，他需要找到本·富兰克林以某种方式隐藏的眼镜，并获得正确的组合，
then suddenly on the back of the declaration of independence he sees this map to me archetypes are very similar they're always there they're always visible but you can only see them if you if you put on a certain set of lenses they're not literal lenses like that it's a way of seeing and that's something you can learn and once you learn that life becomes pretty interesting so for instance the chocolate mousse isn't just a chocolate mousse but is also then filled with the archetype of the lover or venus or beauty or or seduction or chocolate or all those things that belong in that same archetype like you said it's not just the samurai and the and the knight but the warrior shows up in every person in some way shape or form can be your drive your passion your your sort of instinctual targeting your um your force your your ability
然后突然间，在《独立宣言》的背面，他看到了这张地图。对我来说，原型非常相似。它们一直都在那里，一直可见，但只有当你戴上特定的镜片时，你才能看到它们。它们不是那种字面意义上的镜片，而是一种观察方式，这是你可以学习的。一旦你学会了，生活就会变得非常有趣。例如，巧克力慕斯不仅仅是巧克力慕斯，它还充满了情人、维纳斯、美、诱惑或巧克力等原型，以及所有属于同一原型的元素。正如你所说，这不仅仅是武士和骑士，战士以某种形式出现在每个人身上，可以是你的动力、激情、本能的目标、你的力量、你保护自己的能力，
to defend yourself all these kinds of things so we have to look much bigger than limiting an archetype to something that is you know a literalism like it's my anger or it's my inner warrior. That's much too small. Even though we have to, of course, give them names. And so we do call that part that you just mentioned the warrior, but it's not limited to warrior. Warrior is a very wide concept. And so there's always the limitation of language.
所有这些。所以我们必须看得更广，而不是把原型局限于某种字面意义，比如“这是我的愤怒”或“这是我的内在战士”。那太狭隘了。尽管我们当然必须给它们起名字。所以我们确实把刚才提到的那部分称为战士，但它并不局限于战士。战士是一个非常广泛的概念。所以语言总是有局限性的。
So imagination plays a lot. And the idea is that the words trigger something in the imagination. And when you're talking about, there's archetypes at work. Is that one that you use the most? You've got a couple of different systems and publications. Well, I'm an astrologer. I've been an astrologer for 47 years. That's how I see the world. I'm an archetypal astrologer, which means that I see the archetypes that are also represented
所以想象力发挥了很大作用。其理念是，这些词汇触发了想象力中的某些东西。当你谈论“工作中的原型”时，这是你最常使用的吗？你有几种不同的系统和出版物。嗯，我是一名占星家。我已经做了47年的占星家。这就是我看待世界的方式。我是一名原型占星家，这意味着我将行星所代表的原型视为我理解世界的公式。想想键盘上的12个音符，5个黑键和7个白键，它们构成了一个八度音阶，用这些你可以演奏几乎任何歌曲。所以这也是同样的道理，行星原型——我们占星家倾向于使用的那10个——是某种基础，这10个数字可以让你掌握任何情况、描述任何人、任何事物、任何艺术作品，任何你想要的。这是一种原型观察方式。如果你愿意，这些就是镜片，或者是它们的组合。这就是我所使用的。
in the planets as sort of the formula through which I understand the world. Think of the 10 notes of a key, the 12 notes of a keyboard, five black and seven white, that make up an octave and with those you can play pretty much any song. And so this is the same idea that the planetary archetypes, those 10 that we tend to use as astrologers, are sort of the basis, the 10 digits with which you can grasp any situation, describe any person, anything, any piece of art, anything you want. It's an archetypal way of seeing. Those are the lenses, if you want, or combinations of them. And so that's what I use.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
Now, we started to, my partner and I, in 2016, started with them with organizations with this work and so we translated the astrological language into an archetypal language that is more universal and doesn't bump up against some of the pushback against astrology because it has you know a name it's a way of thinking it's not it's it's it's not um you know astrology that's in the back of a magazine that tells you your sun sign it It's definitely not sun sign astrology. What I do, a professional astrologer, doesn't do sun sign astrology. That would be like saying, you know, I'm six foot tall and that defines me. There's so much more that defines me than my height.
现在，我和我的合伙人在2016年开始将这项工作应用于组织，我们将占星语言翻译成了一种更通用的原型语言，这样就不会遇到对占星术的一些抵触，因为它有一个名字，它是一种思维方式，它不是那种杂志封底告诉你星座运势的占星术。绝对不是星座占星术。我所做的，作为一名专业占星家，不做星座占星术。那就像说，“我身高六英尺，这就定义了我。”定义我的东西远不止我的身高。
So, you know, besides the sun sign, you have a moon sign, you have a Mars sign, a Venus sign, etc. So the archetypes at work model is essentially the same model as the astrological model. It's one way of seeing the world, which is archetypal, but we use slightly different language and we focus it in its expression to business and to leadership development. Well, and I, you know, your stuff, you're working with businesses, you know, I'm a therapist. And one of the things that I've been really loud about for a long time is how much the reliance on pure empiricism, things that we can reduce totally down to, you know, something that is Cartesian and measurable in a number, which I just don't believe the psyche. I don't believe trauma. I don't believe the soul really can be reduced to a number um i love science i i you know do research and different things um but i've kind of moved into the things that are more conventional wisdom and there's something you know of you're saying it's a lens
所以，除了太阳星座，你还有月亮星座、火星星座、金星星座等等。“工作中的原型”模型本质上与占星模型相同。这是一种观察世界的方式，即原型化的，但我们使用了略有不同的语言，并将其表达聚焦于商业和领导力发展。嗯，我，你知道，你的东西，你和企业合作，你知道，我是一名治疗师。长期以来，我一直大声疾呼的一件事是，对纯粹经验主义的依赖程度有多高，那些我们可以完全还原为笛卡尔式的、可以用数字衡量的东西。我只是不相信心理、创伤或灵魂真的可以被还原为一个数字。我热爱科学，我做研究和各种事情，但我已经转向了更传统的智慧。你所说的“它是一个镜片”，
like it's a mechanism of sorting this energy so that we can understand it and work with it which that seems to me so inevitable in therapy whether it's the mvti whether it's you know kind of you know freudian or depth you know wisdom of we learned that you know you're lovable from the parent of the opposite sex you know but how to be in the world from the parent of the same sex i mean therapy's been doing that forever in ways that are not 100 right or not measurable or not testable but they're still effective in helping us tease apart who we are and understand us. I'm sure you've had some pushback from people. I mean, a ton of the stuff I get if
就像一种整理这种能量的机制，以便我们能够理解它并与之合作，这在我看来在治疗中是不可避免的。无论是MBTI，还是弗洛伊德或深度心理学的智慧——我们了解到你从异性父母那里学会了如何被爱，但从同性父母那里学会了如何在这个世界上生存。我的意思是，治疗学一直在以这种方式进行，虽然不是100%正确，也不是可测量或可测试的，但它们在帮助我们梳理我们是谁以及理解我们方面仍然是有效的。我相信你一定受到过一些人的抵触。我的意思是，我得到的很多东西，如果
I say that I like Jung or that I'm using kind of a somatic archetypal thing to connect people to something, I have people say, well, you must believe all this stuff that I don't believe. You know, and it's like, I didn't say that. all i said was that i was using somatic work or something i don't know how do you how do you make sense of that we all we all this is great what you're saying i agree with you so look we all believe a certain way and see the world in a certain way what's my father used to say it doesn't matter what you believe just be aware what tree you're sitting in when you're believing and i think that's a lovely metaphor because, you know, as long as we're aware that when we say, I don't believe in what I can't measure, that we are operating from a left brain perspective,
我说我喜欢荣格，或者我正在使用某种躯体原型疗法来将人们与某些东西连接起来，人们会说：“好吧，你一定相信所有这些我不相信的东西。”你知道，这就像，我没那么说。我所说的只是我正在使用躯体疗法或类似的东西。我不知道你怎么理解这一点。我们都，这太棒了，你说的我同意。所以，看，我们都有某种信仰，并以某种方式看待世界。我父亲过去常说：“你相信什么并不重要，重要的是当你相信时，你坐在哪棵树上。”我认为这是一个可爱的隐喻，因为，只要我们意识到，当我们说“我不相信我无法衡量的东西”时，我们是从左脑的角度出发的，
this idea that it has to be rational and measurable to be real. That's a perspective. That's a certain tree to sit in. It's not wrong, but it's not the only way to see. And it's just as valid as another way to see. It's just that since the enlightenment, that way of seeing has trumped and has made everything the right way to see and everything else is woo-woo or weird or different. But here's what's happening. This is what's interesting, what's happening in the world right now. So we have a absolute dominance of left brain capacity, and that's what everybody needs to do. That's how you get along.
这种认为它必须是理性的、可衡量的才是真实的观点。这是一种视角。那是坐在某棵树上。它没有错，但它不是唯一的观察方式。它和其他观察方式一样有效。只是自启蒙运动以来，那种观察方式占据了主导地位，使一切都变成了“正确”的观察方式，而其他一切都被视为“巫术”或怪异或不同。但现在发生了什么？这很有趣，现在世界上正在发生的事情。我们拥有绝对的左脑能力优势，每个人都需要这样做。这就是你如何相处，这就是你如何做生意，这就是你如何获胜，这就是你如何——数据驱动、循证、更多数据更好，测量一切。如果你能获得足够的事实，你就能做出正确的决定。这在一个复杂的世界中是有效的。复杂，我对复杂的定义是，例如一辆车，
That's how you do business. That's how you win. That's how you, you know, data-driven, evidence-based, more data is better, you know, measure everything. And if you just get enough facts, you can make the right decision. That works in a complicated world. Complicated, my definition of complicated is a car for instance
是复杂的。它有一堆简单的系统，比如雨刷系统，有几个雨刷、一个按钮、一个储水箱、一些软管和一个泵。如果那个简单系统中的某个东西坏了，你只需更换零件，它就能再次工作。所以所有这些加在一起构成了一辆复杂的车。在一个复杂的世界中，领导力在某种程度上是数据驱动的，这就是过去几百年工业化以来一直运作良好的方式。然而，今天我们不再处于一个复杂的世界，我们生活在一个混乱（Complex）的世界中，区别在于涌现性。事情在一夜之间发生，改变了每个人的
is complicated. It has a bunch of simple systems like the windshield wiper system has you know a couple of wipers and a button and some and a little you know a little reservoir and some hoses and there you go and a pump. if something breaks in that simple system you can just replace the part and it works again and so all of those together makes a complicated car and leadership in a complicated world works being data driven to some extent that's what's worked pretty well for the last you know several hundred years since the industrialization and so on however today we're no longer in a complicated world, we live in a complex world and the difference is emergence. Things happen overnight that change everybody's
竞争环境，例如新冠疫情或战争，因为我们如此全球化，一切都紧密相连，供应链等等，一切都与一切相互作用。这是一个不同的竞争环境，而“复杂性能力”就是处理那些非线性的、不可预测的事情的能力。如果发生这种情况，那就会发生，或者有七种可能性，我们要选一种等等。所以复杂性能力——这是最酷的地方——是一种右脑能力，属于那些不可衡量的领域：想象力、创造力、做梦、静坐等待灵感迸发、倾听、反思，这些都是右脑能力。
playing field, for instance, COVID or the wars because we're so global and everything is so connected, supply chains, etc., etc., everything interacts with everything else. It is a different playing field and complexity is that capability, what we call complexity capability, to deal with the things that are not linear and that aren't, you know, predictable in that sense that if this happens and that's going to happen or these are the seven possibilities, we're going to pick one and so forth. So complexity capability, and this is the cool thing is a right brain capability that belongs into the realm of those things that aren't measurable imagination creativity dreaming you know sitting still and waiting for something to pop into your mind um uh you know uh listening uh reflecting those kinds of things that's right those are right brain capabilities.
我知道这不是字面意思，并不是说左脑只做一件事，右脑只做一件事。但这种思维方式被普遍理解为什么是左脑能力，什么是右脑能力。所以，不可衡量的世界突然变得极其重要。第二件事发生了，大约18个月前，
And I know this is not literal, it's not that the left brain does one thing and the right brain does one thing. But this way of thinking is very commonly understood what a left brain and a right brain capability is. So the unmeasurable world is actually suddenly incredibly important. Second thing has happened that about 18 months ago,
人工智能出现在现场，领导者们现在突然要处理人工智能。人工智能处理左脑任务的速度比世界上任何领导者都要快亿万倍。因此，许多左脑技能，比如能够获取海量数据并进行分析，然后从中得出解决方案，现在可以由计算机更快地完成。这就是为什么领导者需要激活右脑的另一个原因。换句话说，如果你看看《哈佛商业评论》，人们在谈论什么领导力，每个人现在都在说我们需要激活右脑。盖洛普刚刚做了一项关于此的研究，每个人都在谈论这个，我们需要激活右脑，因为我们想要用
AI popped up on the scene and leaders are now suddenly dealing with AI. AI can do left brain a gazillion times faster than any leader in the world. And therefore, a lot of the left brain skills, like being able to take massive amounts of data and analyze it and then come up with a solution out of that can be done way faster by a computer now and so that's another reason why leaders need to activate their right brain in other words if you look at harvard business review and what are people talking about in leadership everyone is now saying we need to activate our right brain gallup gallup just did a thing on this everyone is talking about this we need to activate our right brains because we want to operate with a
完整的大脑来运作。所以当有人来找你说“你相信所有那些我不相信的东西”时，基本上你可以告诉他们：“我相信完整的大脑，而听起来你只相信使用你一半的大脑。”就是这样，这就是论点。并不是说一个是对的，一个是错的，而是你如何偏好你所看到的东西？所以是的，你和我相信的某些东西，如果你想这么称呼它的话，比如梦、想象力、幻想的重要性，这些创造力发生的地方——顺便说一句，所有这些都是不可衡量的，但它们同样真实。
full brain so when someone comes to you and says what you believe in all that stuff that i don't talking about this we need to activate our right brains because we want to operate with a full brain so when someone comes to you and says what you believe in all that stuff that i don't believe in basically you can just tell them i believe in a whole brain and it sounds like you only believe in using half of your brain that's all that's the argument it's not um that one's right or one's wrong it's what what how are you preferencing what you're looking at? So yes, certain things that you and I believe in, if you want to call it that, like the importance of dreams or imagination or fantasy or those, these kinds of things, um, where creativity takes place, by the way, all of this, um, is not measurable and it is just as real.
嗯，我给你举一个商业中不可衡量但极其真实的东西。它叫信任。任何商业领袖都会说：“天哪，我真的必须强调它，如果人们不信任我，我就不会有生意，我就不会有员工留下来，等等。”所以信任是不可衡量的，但它是非常真实的，在某种意义上它是真实的。所以这是一种右脑能力。所以我们所倡导的只是发展人们的右脑能力。我也非常支持左脑。
Um, I'll give you something in business that is not measurable. That is incredibly real. It's called trust, right? Trust any business leader with would say oh my god i really have to press it people don't trust me i'm not going to have a business i'm not going to have employees and stay and so on so trust isn't measurable but it's very real it's very tangible in that sense that it's real so that's a right brain capability so these kinds of things so all we're advocating for is to develop people's right brain capabilities. I'm also very much in favor of left brain.
我热爱左脑。我热爱我们拥有科学，我拥有工程学位，我们可以拥有清洁的水，进行良好的手术。这当然都很棒，但这还不够。这只是现实的一半。在这个复杂的世界里，我们必须使用我们的大脑整体，我们需要学习一种语言来进行右脑开发，猜猜怎么着？这正是“工作中的原型”所做的。它是一种语言，通过理解
I love left brain. I love that we have science and that we have, I have an engineering degree that we can have, you know, clean water and do good surgery. That's all wonderful, of course, but it's not enough. It's only half of reality. And in this complex world, we have to use our whole brain and we need to learn a language to do right brain development and guess what that's exactly what archetypes at work does it is a language that develops people's right brains and gives them access to their creativity through the imagination by understanding
这些指引我们生活的内在模式，通过想象力来发展人们的右脑，并让他们获得创造力。关于你提到的树的引语很有趣。我想，你显然比我更了解你父亲。所以如果这种直觉在这里是错误的，请纠正我。但我通过所有这些磁带接触到了荣格。这是一些数字化后的磁带，曾经是70、80和90年代的模拟磁带，
these inner patterns that are that are what would guide us through life it's interesting the quote about trees that you mentioned. I think, and you obviously know your father better than I do. So please correct me if this is, the intuition is wrong here, but I came to Jung by all of these tapes. It was this digitized thing of tapes that were once analog from the 70s and 80s and 90s
记录了不同人发表的所有这些演讲。其中一些是詹姆斯·希尔曼，你的父亲。有时我觉得他在思考树，甚至没有提到它，因为他懂很多语言，他懂很多哲学和认识论的方法，他把这些看作是分支，等等。有一次，当他安慰某人时，那个人告诉他他的演讲简直是胡扯——那是在90年代录音中的一位认知治疗师，他说：“我不知道，我正在为此获取治疗CD，我不明白这与病人有什么关系。”而他说：“你知道，所有的认识论和哲学，它有分支，它有分支，你知道，我们体验这些事情的很大一部分原因只是为了说，‘好吧，我喜欢斯宾诺莎。我不理解柏拉图。’这就是我的思维方式，去找到我们的思维方式。”所以我很高兴你找到了你的思维方式。我不知道。是的，那是同一回事。
of all these talks different people gave. And some of them were James Hill james hillman your dads and um the the quote i feel like sometimes he was thinking about trees without even mentioning it because he knew a lot of languages and he knew a lot of methods of philosophy and epistemology that he kind of saw as branching off and the like uh he there's one time where it came up where he was kind of reassuring somebody who was telling he was reassuring someone who was telling him that his presentation was bullshit basically it was like kind of a cognitive therapist in the night in the 90s recording who was like i don't
这是一个美丽的例子和一个伟大的故事。没错。我们必须停止认为我们的思维方式是正确的方式——这就是棘手的地方——或者认为别人的思维方式是错误的方式——这就是棘手的地方。他们只是在不同的树上。不过，认识到我们思维的后果很重要。所以，如果我的思维方式认为所有右脑的东西都是错的，那么我就是在有意识地、积极地排斥它。我也可以说：“我不习惯它，或者我对它了解不多，或者我想了解更多。”对我来说，这更有趣。而一个完全沉浸在右脑中，对左脑一无所知的人——这种情况很少见，但你确实会发现这些人，他们也相当怪异。他们可能坐在果阿的海滩上抽大麻。
know i'm getting a therapy cd for this and i don't understand what this has to do with patients or something and he was saying like you know all of epistemology and philosophy it branches off and it branches off and you know a ton of the reason why we experience these things is just to say, well, I like Spinoza. I don't understand Plato. And this is the way that I think and to find our way of thinking. So I'm so glad that you found your way of thinking or something. And I don't know. Yeah, that's the same thing.
是的。所以在印度。所以也许，你知道，那对我来说也不是完全正常运作的。但一个完全发育的大脑，你知道，用大脑的两侧运作，才是真正必要的。这意味着要进入那些神秘、黑暗和潮湿的地方，你知道，很多
That's a beautiful example and a great story. Exactly. It's not we have to stop thinking that our way of thinking is the right way that's where it gets tricky or that the other person's way of thinking is the wrong way that's that's where it gets tricky they're just in a different tree it is important to recognize consequences of our thinking though and so if my if my way of thinking thinks that everything that is right brain is wrong then then I am consciously and actively excluding it. I could also say I'm not comfortable with it, or I don't know much about it, or I'd
人不想去的地方，那些不理性、不可衡量、不容易解释，但同样真实、同样正确的地方。是的。而且我认为你确实看到了那些躲在隐喻的神秘大脑侧面的人，你知道，可能是在荣格的事物周围。我的意思是，对许多应用荣格心理学的大批评之一是，人们觉得他们忽视了物质现实。你知道，在70年代，他们说：“我们要改变世界，生态女性主义，并显化这些东西。”他们搞了一个鼓圈，但里根革命还是发生了。你知道，这是很多左翼人士批评荣格学派的地方，我也会同意。我的意思是，
like to know more about it. That to me is more interesting. And somebody who is all in their right brain and knows absolutely nothing left brain, that's rare, but you do find those people, they're pretty weird too. They're probably sitting on goa smoking pot, you know, on the beach. Yeah. So in India. So maybe that's, you know on the beach yeah so in india so maybe that's you know that's that's also to me not that's not fully functioning either but a fully developed brain you know operating with all of it with with both sides is really what is necessary and that that means getting into those mysterious and dark and moist places that you know a lot of
我属于爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）阵营，我们的大脑有两个部分，它们并不真的想在同一个脑袋里，而我们要躲在我们擅长的那一个里，因为我们不想处理我们不擅长的那一个。这和你说的有关吗？是的，但那是有代价的。人们不喜欢代价。如果你回避你的右脑，或者认为“这就是我在私生活中做的，而在工作中我只做我的工作”，那是非常分裂的，真的不能造就一个完整的人，你在任何地方都没有充分展现自己。我在我的实践中，已经看到那种行为很多很多次了，这对人们来说是不满足的。然后总是有东西缺失。要么
people don't want to go to that are not rational, not measurable, not so easily explainable, but just as real and just as true. Yeah. And I think you do see the people who hide in the metaphorical mystical side of the brain, you know, probably around Jungian things. I mean, that's one of the big criticisms of a lot of the applied Jungianism was that, you know, they feel like they ignore the material reality that, you know, in the 70s, they said, we're going to change, you know, ecofeminism in the world and manifest these things. And they did a drum circle and the Reagan revolution still happened. You know, that's something that a lot of kind of left people criticize the Jung jungians for and i would kind of agree i mean
他们觉得自己在工作中像个机器人，只是机械地工作，我只是为了领薪水，进进出出，然后回家才有我的感受。或者他们在家里时，在感受上完全优柔寡断，以至于他们根本没有任何结构，完全受制于别人的突发奇想，或者诸如此类的共依赖关系，等等。但在家里没有理性的方式来处理他们的行为。所以如果是这样的话，那不是我想过的生活。我不想在去工作时把一半的自己留在门外。所以我认为，充分展现自己，当我们用这个“工作中的原型”模型与大公司和其中的员工合作时，我们得到的第一件事就是人们说：“我从未以这种方式被看见。我从未以这种完整的方式被交谈过。我从未因我的完整性而被认可。我总是因为我的技能，或者我的技术能力，或者我的职位描述而被看见，但从未被当作一个人。”而在当今世界，我认为盖洛普最近的民意调查显示，60%或70%——一些令人难以置信的数字——的人希望在未来六个月内换工作。这是去年十月的数据，如果我没记错的话，别引用我的话，但它就在那个范围内。想象一下，对于招聘经理
i'm in that edward edinger camp of we've got two parts of our brain they don't really want to be in the same head and we're going to hide in the one that we're back we're going to hide in the one that we're good at because we don't want to deal with the one that we're bad at is that related to what you're saying yeah but yeah but um that has a that has a cost people don't like costs there's a huge cost if you if you avoid your right brain and and and and you know or think that's what i do in my private life and at work i just do my my life that's incredibly split and really doesn't make for a full human being and you're not showing up fully anywhere and that i've seen you know in my practice i've seen that kind of behavior many many many many many times and that's not fulfilling for people. And then there's always something missing. Either
或任何类型的领导者来说，这种人员流动的成本是令人难以置信的。所以，那是在就业市场非常好等等的时候。现在它又下降了一点，所以找工作稍微难了一点。重点是人们在工作中不快乐，因为他们没有被充分看见，他们只是在做一份工作。所以人们希望改变，希望被更多地看见。我们正在完全重新思考工作的意义，主要是因为人工智能。
they feel like they're, you know, they're a robot at work, and it's just mechanic, and I'm just here to make a paycheck and get in and get out, and then I go home and have my feelings. Or they are so completely wishy-washy in their feelings when they're at home that they have absolutely no structure on them at all, and are completely subject to someone else's whims or stuff like that codependency you name it those kinds of things but there's no way of rationally engaging with their behavior at home so if that's the case that's not a life i would like to live i don't want to leave half of myself at the door when i go to work so i think you know showing up fully and the number one thing we get when we use this archetypes at work model with large corporations and people working in them is that people say, I've never
嗯，我认为这是深度心理学和任何基于部分的心理学的真正美妙之处和好处之一，那就是你能够真正深入进去，有人想走进房间，以“逻辑者”或他们的逻辑能力与你交谈，或者他们想以CEO或战士的身份交谈。
been seen this way. I've never been talked to in this full way. I've never been sort of recognized for my fullness. I've always been seen for my skills or for my, you know, technical abilities or for my job description, but never as a human being. And in today's world where I think the last Gallup poll, 60 or 70, some incredible number of people would like to change their jobs within the next six months. This was last October, if I remember correctly, don't quote me on this, but it was in those ranges, is extremely, imagine for a hiring manager
而你说：“不，不，不，我想和你的这一部分交谈。”你开始与他们不习惯交谈的那一部分对话。突然间，你暴露并为某些东西腾出了空间，你正在帮助他们理解。你知道，并非每种治疗都能做到这一点。我认为一些后荣格学派的东西存在风险，因为他们系统化得太多了。比如，我不讨厌IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）。我的意思是，我认为它比CBT（认知行为疗法）好，但你没有把这些东西仅仅视为能量来尊重。所以你开始不得不评判它们。比如，我讨厌“保护者部分”这个词，你知道，这就像，不，它是——是的。哦，我很高兴从一位治疗师那里听到这个。我
or for any kind of a leader, the costs of that kind of a turnover, it's unbelievable. So, and that was when the market was really good for jobs and so on. Now it's gone down a little bit again, so a little bit harder to get jobs. The point is that people aren't happy at work because they're not being fully seen and they're just doing a job. And so people want to change in the hopes they're going to be more seen. And we're rethinking what work is about completely, mostly because of AI.
也有同样的感觉。我认为内在家庭系统疗法（IFS）的想法很好，即我们有多个内在声音，它们相互交谈，这很好。但他们使用的实际标签对我来说也非常非常困难，因为我想不出比试图让某人梳理他们此刻感受到的能量更浪费时间的事情了，我们可以谈论它，但它是“消防员”还是“保护者”？就像，停下，那是大脑中错误的部分，不要把它们放在那里。就像，你知道，他们现在在思考它，你知道，这相当出色，Joel。我从未听过有人把这一点解释得那么好。我一直知道它的标签有些奇怪，我不喜欢，但我们也
Well, I think that's one of the real beauties and benefits of adept psychology and any kind of parts-based psychology is that you're able to really reach in and somebody wants to come into the room and talk to you as the logisticon or their logical faculty, or they want to talk as the CEO or the warrior oristicon, you know, their logical faculty, or they want to talk
要给它应有的赞誉，因为它是一个内在多样性的系统，它是一个与你自己的部分交谈的系统，它是一个理解复杂性的系统。而关于你内心有不止一个声音的整个事情——你知道，发展心理学通常说你是这样的，你知道，先爬，然后走，然后跑，这几乎是大多数发展心理学的模型。然后行为主义，你知道，只是介入其中，那完全是关于你在这些阶段中的某一个阶段表现如何。但所有这些模型都有一个共同点：它们认为人类在内部是单一的。“我是这个”，你知道，身份，
as, you know, the CEO or the warrior or whatever. And you say, no, no, no, I want to talk to this part of you. And you start to talk to this part that they're not used to, that they're not used to conversing. And all of a sudden you've exposed and made room for something that you're helping them understand. You know, not every kind of therapy can do that. And the risk, I think, of some of the post-Jungian things where they systematize too much. Like I, I, I don't hate IFS. I mean, I think it's better than the CBT or something, but you're, you're not respecting these things as just energy. And so you're starting to have to judge them. Like, I hate the term protective part, you know, it's like, no, it's Yeah. Oh, I'm so happy to hear this from a therapist i
身份的整个事情，然后你可以进入身份政治和所有这些事情。但这些整个事情——“我就是那个”，那给了我力量——从原型角度来看，我的自我（ego）是一堆废话，因为根本没有所谓的“我”，有“我”们。我们内部有多个部分。顺便说一句，你可以很容易地向一个坚信那个内在“我”、那个单一“我”的人展示这一点：你有没有和自己交谈过？嗯，当然，我今天早上就在想我应该吃吐司还是麦片，你知道，或者我应该吃这个还是那个。但当然，那有点像个笑话。但如果你在想：“我应该和这个人在一起吗？我应该离开这个人吗？我应该保留这份工作吗？或者那个怎么样？我可以接受这份工作，但我有所有这些选择。”那些权衡利弊的对话，如果你是一个单一的身份，你是做不到的。你只有在从你自己——无论那个自我是什么——抽离出来时才能做到。所以对我来说，你正在从一个内在角色走向另一个内在角色，它们正在进行对话。如果你能识别出这些角色是谁，那是非常有用的，因为这样你就知道它们是如何做决定的。是梦想家和讲故事的人吗？嗯，一个会给另一个讲一个伟大的故事，
get the same i have the same thing i think internal family systems has the ideas great that we have multiple inner voices and they speak to each other that's great but the actual labels that they use are very very um difficult for me as well because i can't think of a bigger waste of time than trying to get somebody to tease apart the energy that they're feeling right now that we could talk about but is it a firefighter or is it a protect like stop what that's the wrong part of the head don't put them there like you know they're thinking about it now you know that's quite brilliant joel i've never i've never heard somebody um explain it to me um that well i always knew there was something weird with it with the labeling that i didn't like but but let's also
而另一个会进入梦境，可能不会那么务实。当你认识到我们实际上是如何感受自己时，这些都是有用的东西。我们内部住着人。我们内部不是单一的。就是这样，有一句可爱的引语。我在我的一本书的开头引用了它，查尔斯·辛尼克（Charles Simic）的一句精彩引语，他
give it credit because it is a system of inter multiplicity it is a system of talking to parts of yourself it is a system that that that understands complexity and this whole thing about having more than one voice inside you know developmental psychology typically says you're this you know first you crawl then you walk then you run that's pretty much the model of of most developmental psychologies and um and then behaviorism you know just comes in there and and that's all about you know how are you behaving in a particular in a particular one of these phases but all of these models have one thing in common they think of a human being as being singular inside i am this and and you know identity the
是几年前美国的桂冠诗人。他写道：“我们大多数时候并不生活在崇高的状态中。我们意识流的内容通常并不那么高尚。我们的心理生活更像是一个吵吵闹闹的剧团，试图排练一出我们不知道名字的戏。”你知道，那真的就是那种感觉。有这种内在的混乱，我们大多数人可以立即产生共鸣。现在，当我写我的论文时，我发现，你知道，你总是必须找到对位，反向的声音。我发现了一群非常非常害怕这个规则的精神科医生。“不要谈论多样性。那意味着分裂人格，DID（解离性身份障碍）。”那是一个完全不同的
whole thing of identity then you can get into identity politics and all these things but these whole things that i am that that's what gives me strength my ego is is from a multi from an archetypal perspective a bunch of baloney because there is no such thing as an eye there are eyes there are multiple parts in us and by the way the way you can easily show this to someone who's a big believer in that interior eye that singular eye have you ever had a conversation with yourself well of course i did this morning i was wondering if i should have toast or or cereal you know or i was and this should have this or that but of course that's kind of a joke but if you're like should i stay with this person should i leave this
东西。那是一种疾病，与我们现在谈论的说话方式毫无关系。将两者等同起来是极其天真和极其简单化的。多样性，内在多样性是人类几千年来思考自己的方式。如果是内在的神，或多个神，或者，你知道，外部然后反映在内部，如果是这些——我的意思是，深度心理学的天赋就是带给我们这种内在的多样性。
person should i keep this job or what about that i could take this job but i have all these options those conversations weighing the pros and the cons you can't do if you're a single identity you can only do that when you step away from yourself whatever that self is so to me you're stepping from one inner character to another inner character and they're having a conversation and if you can identify who these characters are that's very useful because then you know how they make decisions. Is it the dreamer and the storyteller? Well, one's gonna tell the other one a great story
那真的是最伟大的礼物。然后荣格通过全球性地观察它们，给它们起了名字，称它们为原型。但这是大事。现在我前几天刚遇到一位精神科医生，她写了一篇文章，我和她建立了联系，因为我一直在写关于领导力中的内在多样性。她写了一篇关于，你知道，从精神科医生的角度来看，也许内在多样性并不意味着解离性身份障碍，可能真的意味着——从精神科医生的角度来看，也许内在多样性并不意味着解离性身份障碍。它真的可能意味着，你知道，一种更丰富的思维方式。所以我对这种现在开始的运动非常感兴趣。
and the other one's gonna go into dreams and maybe not be so practical. These are useful things to have as you recognize how we actually feel ourselves. We are peopled inside. We are not singular inside. That's it, there's this lovely quote. I have it in the beginning of one of my books this wonderful quote by Charles Sinek he was
嗯，它已经持续了一段时间，但现在它获得了一些关注，即内在多样性是好的。有一种语言可以表达它。在我们的案例中，我们使用基于行星的原型。对我来说，这是一个非常坚实的基础，5000年的数据——如果你想用左脑来量化这一点——关于行星对一个人意味着什么。所以，你知道，当你这么说时，你的意思是存在着永恒的模式，我们可以回头看看这些东西再次出现。我的意思是，因为，我的意思是，这就是我的论点，当人们说“好吧，它不是——”回头看看这些东西再次出现。我的意思是，因为，我的意思是，这就是我的论点，当人们说……
the poet laureate in the United States a couple of years ago he wrote we do not live most of the time in exalted states the content of our stream of consciousness is usually not so lofty our psychic life is more like a squabbling squabbling theatrical company trying to rehearse a play we don't know the name of you know that's really how it feels there's this inner mess most of us can immediately relate to that now when i wrote my dissertation i found you know you always have to find the counterpoint the counter voice and i found a bunch of psychiatrists who are very, very afraid of this rule. Don't talk about multiplicity. That means split personality, DID, you know, dissociative identity disorder. That's a completely different
几年前，美国桂冠诗人曾写道：我们大多数时候并非生活在崇高的状态中，我们意识流的内容通常并不那么高尚。我们的心理生活更像是一个吵吵闹闹的剧团，试图排练一出我们连名字都不知道的戏。你知道，这确实就是那种感觉。大多数人都能立刻体会到那种内在的混乱。当我写论文时，我发现你总是需要找到对立面、反面声音，我发现了一群非常非常害怕这个规则的精神科医生。不要谈论多重性。那意味着分裂人格、DID，你知道，分离性身份识别障碍。那是完全不同的
thing. That is an illness and has nothing to do with the way of speaking that we speak now. And to equate one with the other is incredibly naive and incredibly simplistic. Multiplicity, inner multiplicity is how human beings have thought about themselves for eons. If it was inner gods or multiple gods or, you know, outside and then reflected inside, if it was these, I mean, the gift of death psychology has been to bring us this inner multiplicity.
一回事。那是一种疾病，与我们现在所说的这种表达方式毫无关系。将两者等同起来是极其天真和极其简单化的。多重性，内在的多重性，是人类几千年来思考自身的方式。无论是内在的神灵、多神论，还是外部反映到内部，我的意思是，深度心理学的贡献就在于为我们带来了这种内在的多重性。
That's really been the greatest gift. And then Jung gave them names and called them archetypes by looking at them globally. But this is the big thing. And now I just met a psychiatrist the other day who wrote an article and I connected with her because I've been writing about inner multiplicity in leadership. And she wrote one about, you know, from a psychiatrist's perspective, that maybe inner multiplicity doesn't mean dissociative identity disorder could really mean, you know, from a psychiatrist's perspective, that maybe intermultiplicity doesn't mean dissociative identity disorder. It could really mean, you know, a richer way of thinking. So I'm very interested in this sort of movement that's starting now.
这确实是最大的贡献。荣格通过全球性的视角观察它们，并为它们命名，称之为原型。但这是重点。前几天我遇到一位精神科医生，她写了一篇文章，我与她取得了联系，因为我一直在撰写关于领导力中内在多重性的文章。她从精神科医生的角度写道，也许内在多重性并不意味着分离性身份识别障碍，它可能真的意味着一种更丰富的思维方式。所以我对这种刚刚开始的运动非常感兴趣。
And, well, it's been going on for a while, but now it's getting some traction that intermultiplicity is good. There is a language for it. In our case, we use archetypes based on the planets. To me, that's a very solid foundation 5 000 years of data if you want to use left brain just to quantify that of how what the planets mean you know for a person and so and so you know and when you say that you mean that there's you know perennial patterns that we can go back and look at these things popping up i mean because i mean that's my argument when people say well it's not back and look at these things popping up. I mean, because, I mean, that's my argument when people say,
嗯，这种情况已经持续了一段时间，但现在开始获得一些关注，即内在多重性是件好事。对此有一套语言体系。在我们的案例中，我们使用基于行星的原型。对我来说，这是一个非常坚实的基础，如果你想用左脑来量化的话，有五千年的数据记录了行星对个人的意义。当你这么说时，你的意思是存在着永恒的模式，我们可以回头看看这些事物是如何涌现的。因为我的论点是，当人们说，嗯，这不是
well, it's not empirical to look at mythology. It's not empirical for you to look at these gurus and mystics that you're writing about on your blog. You know, why are you writing about Martin Buber? Why are you writing about Meister Eckhart? And I'm saying, like, because when somebody invents Buddhism in the middle of medieval Germany, that means that there is some part of the brain that produces this
嗯，研究神话并不是经验性的。你研究博客里写的那些大师和神秘主义者也不是经验性的。你知道，你为什么要写马丁·布伯？为什么要写迈斯特·埃克哈特？我想说的是，因为当有人在中世纪的德国发明了佛教时，这意味着大脑中确实有某种部分产生了这种东西。
because Meister Eckhart didn't go study in Japan, or he didn't go study, you know, in Thailand. And so that means that this is a description, you know, people are universally arriving at these places because of archetypal or some kind of inborn thing. And I don't care where you think it comes from. You can have a woo-woo spiritual metaphysics, you can have a scientific genetically deterministic, biological deterministic metaphysics. I'm just pointing out the pattern, you know? And if you can't see the pattern or that, that seems more empirical to me than people want it to be.
因为迈斯特·埃克哈特并没有去日本学习，也没有去泰国学习。所以这意味着这是一种描述，你知道，人们因为原型或某种与生俱来的东西而普遍地到达这些地方。我不在乎你认为它来自哪里。你可以有那种虚无缥缈的精神形而上学，也可以有科学的基因决定论、生物决定论的形而上学。我只是指出这种模式，你知道吗？如果你看不出这种模式，或者说，这对我来说比人们想要的更具经验性。
But isn't that a strange question to ask you? Why would you study Eckhart or why would you, in other words, to me, you know would you study at Carter why would you in other words to me you know you're a psychologist you know as a psychologist thinking person you would ask yourself what is that person so afraid of why are thoughts dangerous yeah thoughts are dangerous because they they might they might actually open up a part of myself that I'm terrified of you know it's like I'm never gonna fall in love and going to fall in love. I'm never going to fall in love.
但问你这个问题不是很奇怪吗？你为什么要研究埃克哈特，或者换句话说，对我来说，你是一个心理学家，作为一个心理学思考者，你会问自己那个人在害怕什么？为什么思想是危险的？是的，思想是危险的，因为它们可能会真正打开我内心深处我所恐惧的部分，你知道，就像我永远不会坠入爱河，却坠入了爱河。我永远不会坠入爱河。
Oh, damn, I just fell in love. Now what? It's like these things, people are so worried that because you can't measure it, it's not real. It's just, I mean, someone says that to me, why do you study that? It's not even empirical. I burst out laughing. This is the conversations going on in research between quantitative and qualitative research. Someone who's a quantitative researcher who only believes
哦，该死，我刚刚坠入爱河了。现在怎么办？就像这些事情，人们非常担心因为无法衡量它，它就不是真实的。我的意思是，有人对我说，你为什么要研究那个？那甚至不是经验性的。我大笑起来。这就是定量研究和定性研究之间正在进行的对话。一个只相信分析数据、海量数据并从中寻找真理的定量研究人员会说，人类科学所使用的每一种定性研究都是无效的。
in analyzing data, massive amounts of data, and finding truth in there is going to say that every kind of qualitative research, which is what the human sciences use, is invalid. And so, you know, it's two minds that don't meet, but they're talking about two different sides of the brain and two different sides of perceiving reality. And meanwhile, there is tons and tons and tons and tons of very valid research done on quality, with quality, with a qualitative, from a qualitative perspective.
所以，你知道，这是两个无法交汇的思想，但它们谈论的是大脑的两个不同侧面和感知现实的两个不同侧面。与此同时，从定性角度出发，针对定性研究已经完成了大量非常有效的研究。
So I'm just, I just don't, I don't get engaged in a in a confrontative argument i think it's a waste of time it's like stay in your tree that's fine just be aware that you're in a tree i don't have a problem with that but the qual even if you want to stay in the realm of the quantitative they don't give um you know jung and and and hellman like the credit that they deserve now that we have qEGs that say it's not about the part of the brain, it's about networks that you're activating of deep somatic emotion that is coming from the brainstem in a theta wave. And this is how you experience being assertively,
所以我只是，我只是不参与对抗性的争论，我认为那是浪费时间。就像待在你的树上，那很好，只要意识到你在树上就行了，我对此没有意见。但即使你想留在定量的领域，他们也没有给予荣格和希尔曼应有的认可。现在我们有了定量脑电图（qEEG），它表明这与大脑的某个部分无关，而是与你激活的深层躯体情绪网络有关，这些情绪来自脑干的θ波。这就是你体验果断的方式，
assertive is the warrior. This is how you experience being passively controlling. These are your emotions obsessed. One of them is good. One of them is bad. One of them tightens my entire back because I have trauma around that. It's these networks of deep semantic and emotional memory, you know, and the same people, the same people who said that Jung was kind of fleet BS and published those papers in the nineties are publishing now and saying, oh, well there's primary, secondary, and tertiary memory. There's, there's, there's first order, second order, and third order thought processes. The third order can only really be engaged through the body and through symbolic content.
果断就是战士。这就是你体验被动控制的方式。这些是你痴迷的情绪。其中一个是好的，一个是坏的。其中一个让我的整个背部紧绷，因为我对此有创伤。这些是深层语义和情绪记忆的网络，你知道，同样是那些说荣格是胡说八道并在九十年代发表这些论文的人，现在却在发表文章说，哦，有初级、二级和三级记忆。有第一级、第二级和第三级思维过程。第三级思维只能通过身体和象征性内容真正参与。
It's like that's what they're publishing now. Right. But they weren't wrong. Yeah. Here's the thing. People are, you know, when you think about, you know, that makes Jung's work even more interesting because in a way he was doing all of this before we knew everything that we know today so that's
就像他们现在发表的内容一样。没错。但他们并没有错。是的。事情是这样的。人们，你知道，当你想到这一点时，这让荣格的工作变得更加有趣，因为在某种程度上，他在我们今天所知的一切之前就已经在做所有这些事情了，所以这就是
we have to keep that in mind think about when you know people who attack jung for not being feminist enough or so forth everybody's influenced by their times of course they are and and i agree a lot of what jung says is you know is's like scratching a blackboard in the wrong way with your fingernails. I'm not sure if you can still hear me, but you've frozen for a second. So I'm waiting for the connection to catch up. Are we good? I can hear you now. Cut out for just a second.
我们必须记住这一点。想想那些攻击荣格不够女权主义等等的人，每个人当然都受到他们所处时代的影响。我同意，荣格所说的大部分内容就像是用指甲在黑板上乱划。我不确定你还能不能听到我说话，但你刚才卡住了一秒钟。所以我正在等连接恢复。我们好了吗？我现在能听到你了。刚才断了一秒钟。
The last thing I heard was scratching of the fingernails. Sorry. Oh, yes. it cut out for just a second. Last thing I heard was scratching of the fingernails. Sorry. Oh yes, I said, you know, some of what Jung said is like scratching fingernails across the blackboard. I get it, but that's in today's context because we now have feminism, we have, you know, enlightenment in lots of areas that we didn't have before, in right brain capabilities and understanding of, you know, that anima is limited to the man and animals to the woman these kinds of things is is pretty is pretty limited so so um but it doesn't mean you don't throw out the baby with the bathwater it doesn't mean that what jung said wasn't absolutely brilliant and and and mind-blowing and and trailblazing that's the key the other thing is that most people who criticize for instance astrology i've heard so much criticism about astrology have absolutely no idea what they're
我听到的最后一件事是指甲划过黑板的声音。抱歉。哦，是的，刚才断了一秒钟。我听到的最后一件事是指甲划过黑板的声音。抱歉。哦，是的，我说过，荣格所说的一些话就像是指甲划过黑板。我明白，但那是在今天的背景下，因为我们现在有了女权主义，我们在许多领域有了启蒙，而这些是我们以前没有的，在右脑能力和理解方面，你知道，阿尼玛仅限于男性，阿尼姆斯仅限于女性，这些东西是相当有限的。所以，但这并不意味着你要把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉。这并不意味着荣格所说的话不是绝对的辉煌、令人震惊和开创性的。这就是关键。另一件事是，大多数批评占星术的人，我听过太多关于占星术的批评，他们根本不知道自己在批评什么。
criticizing yeah and so for me it's like you know Newton had a famous because Newton studied astrology and Newton had a famous line somewhere you know when some other scientists said to him oh you know the second astrology is nothing and he said sir I have studied it and you have not that's all he said and so it's like to me I have no problems and you have not. That's all he said. And so it's like, to me, I have no problems with somebody who really knows astrology to say, oh, it's a bunch of baloney, but to outright say, there can't be a connection between the planets and us.
是的，所以对我来说，就像牛顿有一句名言，因为牛顿研究过占星术，牛顿在某处有一句名言，当其他科学家对他说，哦，你知道占星术什么都不是，他说，先生，我研究过它，而你没有。这就是他所说的。所以对我来说，我没有问题，而你没有。这就是他所说的。所以对我来说，我并不介意真正了解占星术的人说，哦，那是一堆废话，但直接说，行星和我们之间不可能有联系。
You know, it surprises me how afraid people are about those things that they can't measure. And it's as though if you say you believe in astrology that immediately makes you a weak you know a gullible because most people associate astrology with crap which is what's in the back of a magazine which is nothing to do with real astrology so you know pop psychology is also very crappy you know I'm an introvert I'm an extrovert really doesn't mean very much and these sort of simple labels I mean I'm an Aries I'm a
你知道，人们对那些无法衡量的事情感到如此恐惧，这让我感到惊讶。就好像如果你说你相信占星术，那立刻就让你变得软弱，你知道，容易受骗，因为大多数人把占星术与垃圾联系在一起，也就是杂志背后的那些东西，那与真正的占星术无关。所以你知道，流行心理学也非常糟糕，你知道，我是内向的，我是外向的，其实并没有多大意义。这些简单的标签，我的意思是，我是白羊座，我是
you know I'm a Libra doesn't really mean anything it's that it's a much more it's a complexity and to really be able to say I think it's a bunch of baloney that's fine but please study it enough to make an intelligent decision and to have some intelligent arguments about why it's baloney rather than just because it can't be that's a really bad argument to me just can't be that there's a connection that means you've not studied it how that connection actually works so what that actually is or how we can look at the planets to get some answers that's just you know quite intelligent people have been um you know giving a lifetime to studying astrology and they've come up with some very interesting
你知道，我是天秤座，这真的没有任何意义。这是一种复杂性，要真正能够说我认为这是一堆废话，那没问题，但请研究得足够深入，以便做出明智的决定，并就为什么它是废话提出一些明智的论点，而不是仅仅因为它不可能。对我来说，那是一个非常糟糕的论点。仅仅因为不可能有联系，就意味着你没有研究过这种联系实际上是如何工作的，它实际上是什么，或者我们如何观察行星来获得一些答案。你知道，相当聪明的人已经花了一辈子时间研究占星术，他们得出了一些非常有趣的
insights and that's worth studying so if somebody's interested in that you know study it and then make a decision if you think it's worthwhile or not but don't dismiss an idea how can anything that cracks us open and shows us uh the way you know different parts of our ourself and gives us a different vantage point on the way we think and make decisions be a bad thing, no matter where it comes from or what you think about the scientific materialism. I mean, I, um, a lot of astrologers have to have, um, if they're licensed a certain way, they, they have, uh, um, a therapist that they refer to, um, because, you know, astrology can't treat certain things. And so just as part of networking, when I opened this,
见解，这是值得研究的。所以如果有人对此感兴趣，你知道，去研究它，然后决定你认为它是否值得。但不要否定一个想法。无论它来自哪里，或者你对科学唯物主义有什么看法，任何能让我们敞开心扉、向我们展示我们不同部分并为我们思考和做决定的方式提供不同视角的东西，怎么可能是坏事呢？我的意思是，很多占星师如果他们以某种方式获得许可，他们会有一位他们推荐的治疗师，因为你知道，占星术无法治疗某些事情。所以作为网络的一部分，当我开设这个时，
I saw Mandy Ray in Birmingham, a couple of people, and I was starting an integrative holistic medicine clinic that was brain-based and depth psychology. And I'm a social worker. It was expensive and it was a real stressful time. And it was incredibly helpful. I don't know a ton about astrology, but the perspective when they were explaining, you know, how I could think about things and things that I should look for and things that I should respond to.
我在伯明翰见过曼迪·雷（Mandy Ray）和几个人，我当时正在创办一家基于大脑和深度心理学的综合整体医学诊所。我是一名社会工作者。这很昂贵，而且那是一段非常紧张的时期。这非常有帮助。我对占星术了解不多，但当他们解释我该如何思考事情、我应该寻找什么以及我应该对什么做出反应时，那个视角
It made me engage with my life in a way that was very helpful. You know, tarot is similar. Some people use tarot, you know, to confront a problem that you're eating. I mean, this stuff is so old. Why is it so threatening to people to give up that control and look at themselves from a different perspective than that thing? Because they're afraid of being called a feeble mind or gullible or these kinds of things.
让我以一种非常有帮助的方式参与到我的生活中。你知道，塔罗牌也类似。有些人使用塔罗牌来面对你正在经历的问题。我的意思是，这些东西太古老了。放弃那种控制权并从与那个东西不同的角度审视自己，为什么对人们来说如此具有威胁性？因为他们害怕被称为头脑简单或容易受骗，或者诸如此类的东西。
Meanwhile, people are extremely gullible by data as well. So it's just, anyway, I think it's great to just make the point let people decide for themselves you know I'm here to tell you that astrology is not some kind of a strange woo-woo thing that you can't learn it's quite rational it can be learned and yes to some extent it's also there's a difference between being a great astrology and being a good astrologer and that is the same difference as being someone who plays the piano well and plays music you know that's that's there's this there's an art part to it that is right brainy and that that you can't learn learn but that is kind of a talent and a gift just like with anything else that you go
与此同时，人们也非常容易被数据所欺骗。所以，总之，我认为指出这一点让人们自己决定是很好的。你知道，我在这里告诉你，占星术不是那种你学不会的奇怪的虚无缥缈的东西。它是相当理性的，是可以学习的。是的，在某种程度上，伟大的占星师和好的占星师之间是有区别的，这和弹钢琴弹得好的人与演奏音乐的人之间的区别是一样的。你知道，这其中有一种艺术成分，是右脑的，是你学不来的，但那是一种天赋，就像你从事的其他任何事情一样。
that same in medicine there's something about being the best student in med school and being a fabulous doctor that's not necessarily the same thing there's another part to healing that is not necessarily measurable you know maybe bedside manners how do you measure that those kinds of things so so yeah it's just it's just that I would like to take some of the some of the stigma out of astrology because it has such a a a it used to have it's changed a lot it is a I read a few years ago the astrology was the second most googled word on google after sex and so i was quite quite impressed by that that people are
医学也是如此，成为医学院最好的学生和成为一名出色的医生之间是有区别的。治疗中还有另一部分不一定是可衡量的。你知道，也许是床边礼仪，你如何衡量这些东西？所以，是的，我只是想消除一些对占星术的污名，因为它曾经有，它已经改变了很多。我几年前读到，占星术是谷歌上搜索次数第二多的词，仅次于性。所以我对此印象非常深刻，人们
really curious especially young people really want to know and you know they want to know and often it stays with their sun sign but at least it's a way to think about themselves fine it's a limited way but it is it's better than nothing it's starting to think that they have a connection to the universe, to their birth minute. And something happened at that moment that continues to unfold in them. And I think that's an interesting way to live rather than just hearing a random speck of dirt in the universe. So, yeah, meaning making is something very important for human beings. And we find our own ways to make meaning. Some people make meaning through a lot of data.
真的很好奇，尤其是年轻人，他们真的想知道。你知道，他们想知道，而且通常它只停留在他们的太阳星座上，但至少这是一种思考自己的方式。很好，这是一种有限的方式，但总比没有好。这开始让他们认为自己与宇宙、与他们出生的那一刻有联系。在那一刻发生了一些事情，并在他们身上持续展开。我认为这是一种有趣的生活方式，而不是仅仅听到宇宙中一个随机的尘埃。所以，是的，意义构建对人类来说是非常重要的。我们找到自己的方式来创造意义。有些人通过大量数据来创造意义。
That's fine. Just be aware that that's your mindset. Yeah, I was in Spain with my family this summer and we went to the Dolmen Dominga, this Neolithic portal tomb and you're looking at this thing that uh is just unbelievably old that somebody moved 100 180 ton rocks to make this long tunnel so that exactly at the winter equinox the light would shine all the way down to the very tip of this tomb and touch the bones you know that were in the end and uh you know just it's one of the first things that we did you know you could you could look at somebody who, you know, there's a mountain, there's a storm. I can build a house, but it'll burn down. I can tell a story, but it'll change.
那很好。只要意识到那是你的思维方式就行。是的，今年夏天我和家人在西班牙，我们去了多明加支石墓（Dolmen Dominga），这是一个新石器时代的门户墓。你看着这个东西，它古老得令人难以置信，有人移动了180吨的岩石来建造这个长隧道，这样在冬至时，光线就会准确地照进这个墓穴的最深处，触碰到里面的骨头。你知道，这只是我们做的第一件事。你可以看看某个人，你知道，有一座山，有一场风暴。我可以盖一所房子，但它会烧毁。我可以讲一个故事，但它会改变。
And then you see that birth of architecture where you build this thing. The psyche is completely different because using math, using intuition, using logic, I'm now talking to God. You know, this 180 ton monument is going to here forever you know from my mind and it's connecting me to this timeless order of cosmology I was able to predict the Sun you know how that moment of change you know that's like one of the moments we came alive in it and it had to do with the cosmos with with the astro very beautiful and you know Joel I think every religion started out well religion in general started out as sun worshipping because, you know, the sun was the giver of life. It's pretty natural to then make sun, you know, raw or in the Inca tradition.
然后你看到了建筑的诞生，你建造了这个东西。心灵是完全不同的，因为使用数学、使用直觉、使用逻辑，我现在正在与上帝对话。你知道，这个180吨的纪念碑将永远存在，从我的思想中，它将我与这种永恒的宇宙秩序联系起来。我能够预测太阳，你知道那种变化的时刻，那就像我们活过来的时刻之一，它与宇宙有关，与天文有关，非常美丽。而且，乔尔，我认为每一种宗教最初都是，宗教通常最初都是太阳崇拜，因为太阳是生命的给予者。那么把太阳变成拉（Ra）或者印加传统中的神，是很自然的。
You know, these were, you know, if you were sitting in your cave shivering and the sun didn't come up the next morning, you know, you'd be dead. No food, no no light no nothing so this idea that you would worship and ask the Sun to come back every day makes a lot of sense so religion started out as Sun and then Sun gods and and so on and the honoring of the Sun and the moon and many traditions are based on the moon and they're regular they're predictable we know where they are at any given time and so we set our calendars according to them too, in a very, in a very, you know, sketchy world that is always reliable. We know where the sun's going to be at any given time. We know where the moon's going to be at any given time. So we can organize our chaotic lives according to them, which is why every calendar is made that way.
你知道，如果你坐在洞穴里发抖，而第二天早上太阳没有升起，你就会死。没有食物，没有光，什么都没有。所以这种你会崇拜并要求太阳每天回来的想法是非常合理的。所以宗教最初是太阳，然后是太阳神等等，对太阳和月亮的尊崇。许多传统都是基于月亮的，它们是有规律的，是可预测的。我们在任何时候都知道它们在哪里，所以我们也根据它们来设定我们的日历。在一个总是不可靠的、草率的世界里，我们知道太阳在任何时候会在哪里，我们知道月亮在任何时候会在哪里。所以我们可以根据它们来组织我们混乱的生活，这就是为什么每个日历都是这样制作的。
Could you let people have some examples of how the archetypes at work could help them directly with leadership if they're doing executive coaching, if they're doing mentoring, if they are a business leader, therapist? Yeah, I'll give you a corporate example and I'll give you a personal example. First, a corporate example, an R and D department research and development department had about 30 people in it. And the, um, leadership looked at the numbers and they found that they'd been giving this department millions of dollars over the last five years. And nothing really came out of this department that was useful or, and so, you know, the first thought, what should we keep them?
你能让人们举一些例子，说明原型在工作中如何直接帮助他们进行领导力提升吗？如果他们正在做高管教练、指导，如果他们是商业领袖、治疗师？好的，我给你一个企业案例，再给你一个个人案例。首先，一个企业案例，一个研发部门大约有30人。领导层查看了数据，发现过去五年他们给了这个部门数百万美元。但这个部门并没有产出任何有用的东西。所以，第一个想法是，我们应该留住他们吗？
Should we fire them? What should we do? Do we have the wrong people? Why, you know, this isn't working what should we keep them? Should we fire them? What should we do? Do we have the wrong people? Why, you know, this isn't working. They should be inventing stuff and so forth. So, or improving stuff or whatever. So they called us in, we did an assessment on everybody. We have an archetypal assessment and found out that nobody in the team, not a single
我们应该解雇他们吗？我们该怎么办？我们用错人了吗？为什么，你知道，这行不通。他们应该发明东西等等。或者改进东西之类的。所以他们叫我们进去，我们对每个人进行了评估。我们有一个原型评估，发现团队中没有人，甚至包括领导团队的人，对他们内心的“叛逆者”感到自在。我们根据舒适度对他们进行了排名，我是否真的对这个感到自在？它在我的生活中是否处于中心位置？我可以轻松地进入它并向世界展示它，还是它在后台休息室里打瞌睡？所以他们中没有人把“叛逆者”排在前三名。所以我们把这份报告给了领导层，他们说，好吧，我想，在过去，他们会做的是解雇这些人。
one of them, including the person who led the team, was comfortable with their inner renegade, was in their, we ranked them by how comfortable am I, am I really comfortable with this one, is it kind of center stage in my life, I can easily step into it and show it to the world, or is it kind of off stage taking a nap in the green room. So none of them had the renegade in the top three. So we gave them this report to leadership and they're like, well, I guess, you know, in the old days, what they would have done is let's fire these people.
我们用错人了。他们不够叛逆。他们不是，叛逆者是我们所有人内心的一部分，是发明家、创造性的打破常规的思考者，不介意规则，走出去做不同的事情。所以我们说，其实你不需要解雇这些人，因为我们知道每个人内心都有一个内在的叛逆者，只是因为某些
We have the wrong people. They're not renegade enough. They're not, the renegade is that part of us in all of us that is the inventor, the creative outside of the box thinker, doesn't mind the rules, goes out and does different things. And so we said, actually actually you don't have to fire these people because we know that everyone within them has an inner renegade it's just that for some
原因他们没有激活它，他们没有展示它。也许他们不敢，也许他们害怕如果他们太突出，他们会被解雇。也许他们小时候被告知永远不要打破规则。为什么，我们不在乎为什么。我们只知道现在，没有人以叛逆者的身份出现在中心舞台上，或者说感到自在。所以我们进去，和那个团队做了一个“叛逆者激活工作坊”。我们花了大约两天时间。
reason they're not activating they're not showing it they're not maybe they don't dare maybe they're afraid if they you know stick out too much they'll get fired maybe they were told as a kid don't ever you know break the rules doesn't why, we don't care why. We just know that right now, nobody's showing up with a renegade center stage or sort of comfortable. So instead we go in and we do a renegade activation workshop with that team. We did that over about two days.
他们很喜欢，这很有趣。大约六个月内，那个团队发明了一些相当著名的东西。所以他们打破了自己的局限。当然，领导层很高兴，因为激活一个原型的成本远低于解雇所有人、雇佣新员工，然后带着新团队重新开始。所以这是一个关于如何在团队中激活原型的实际例子，因为你也可以进行团队评估，找出这个团队在哪些方面不够强大，在哪些方面表现过度等等。所以，一个个人案例是某个人，
They loved it, it was a lot of fun. And within about six months, that team invented something rather well-known. So they broke out of their own limitations. And of course, leadership was delighted because it costs them way less to activate an archetype than it does to fire everyone and hire new people and then start all over again with a new team. So that's a practical example of how activating an archetype in a team, because you can do a team assessment as well and find out what is this team not so strong on and what is this dream really strong on and that they might overplay and so on so um a personal example is someone who
你知道，是一位女性，她想更多地激活她的“战士”，因为它在她的舒适度列表底部。你知道，由于许多历史原因，她对它感到不自在。在教练过程中，你会深入探讨为什么有人在商业环境中可能不喜欢这一点，通常不会，但在与这位女性的教练中，你知道，她的童年和过去有很多原因，你知道，来自一个饱受战争蹂躏的国家等等，战士并没有被视为她真正想很好地获取的东西。这很能理解，但她也看到了不获取那部分自己的代价。所以我们做了大量工作，这意味着每周给她布置家庭作业，做某些事情，写东西，反思这个那个，这完全改变了她。
um you know is a woman who wanted to activate her warrior more because it was at the bottom of her comfort list you know she wasn't comfortable with it for a lot of historical reasons which in coaching you get into deeper things you know what why someone might not like that in a business setting you usually don't but in this coaching with this woman you know there were a lot of reasons in her childhood and in her past that you know coming from a war-torn country and so on where the warrior was not seen as anything she really wanted to access very well understood but she also where the warrior was not seen as anything. She really wanted to access Very well understood, but she also saw the cost of not accessing that part of herself And so we did a whole bunch of work and that means you know Giving her homework every week and doing certain things and writing things and reflecting on this that and the other and it completely changed her
她的婚姻，首先，当这一切开始时，她几乎准备离开她的丈夫。然后，现在一切都进行得非常非常顺利。他们在沟通。这是一个全新的局面。如果她没有找到那种内在的力量来为她所需要的东西大声疾呼，这一切都不会发生。所以这是一件美好的事情。
her her marriage for one thing she was just about ready to leave her husband when that started. And then, you know, now it's all, you know, going really, really great. And they're communicating. It's a whole new thing. That would never have happened had she not found that inner power to speak up for what she needed and so forth. So it's a lovely thing.
而且她已经外化了很多。她的丈夫是非常典型的战士类型，那种走出去获取他所需要的、做事、擅长商业等等的人。所以她正在学习她不必放弃这一点。她实际上可以拥有它，并与她的丈夫进行诚实、严肃和良好的对话，同时她与孩子、工作和其他一切的生活在过去六个月的教练中也发生了巨大的变化。所以，你知道，这是一个关于激活原型如何帮助你的实际例子，它帮助了她的职业生涯。
And she had externalized a lot of it. Her husband is very warrior sort of type and classic sort of that sort of, you know, goes out and gets what he needs and does and is good at business and these kinds of things. So she's learning that she doesn't have to give that away. She can actually own it and have an honest and serious and good conversation with her husband in one place, but also her other life with her kids and with her and with her work and everything else also changed dramatically over the last about six months of coaching so um you know this is a practical example of how activating an archetype can help you helped her in her career
她有一家企业，情况好多了。人们不再随意践踏她，因为她现在找回了自己的力量。所以没有好或坏的原型，关键在于你对它们有多自在，以及你是否能够以一种富有成效的方式表达它们。所以这就是重点。人们想要了解更多关于“工作中原型”的信息，可以去 archetypesatwork.com，然后他们可以直接与我联系，告诉我他们的需求是什么。是个人教练、企业事务、领导团队、运作不理想的董事会，还是一个完整的团队，或者只是一群不在同一个组织但都在同一个组织的人？有很多方法可以处理这个问题。
she has a business it got much better there people weren't walking all over her because she now had you know her own power back and things like that so there are no good or bad archetypes it's just how comfortable are you with them and are you able to express them in a productive way or not so so that's the thing so the way people can get to know more about archetypes at work is to go to archetypes at work.com and then they can connect with me directly and tell me what their needs are is it personal coaching is it a corporate thing is it a leadership team is it a board that's not functioning ideally um is it um you know an intact team is it just a bunch of people who are not an intact team but they're all in the same organization there's so many ways to approach this
所有的“工作中原型”都始于一个问题。你的问题是什么？就像在这个案例中，研发部门没有发明任何东西。这是一个问题。我们知道我们的人员流动率很高。这是一个问题。没有人想在这里工作。
all archetypes at work work starts with a problem. What's your problem? Like in this case, you know, the R&D department isn't inventing anything. That's a problem. We know we have high turnover. That's a problem. Nobody wants to work here.
这是一个问题。我们找不到更多的人。这是一个问题。换句话说，我们没有吸引力。我们的“爱人”并没有真正处于前沿。人们不想和我们一起工作。诸如此类的事情。所以我们然后将问题转化为原型模式，并思考解决它的方法。
That's a problem. We can't find more people. That's a problem. In other words, we're not attractive. Our lover isn't really at the forefront. People aren't wanting to work with us. These kinds of things. So we then translate the problem into an archetypal pattern and think about ways to
这意味着什么，有不同的选择。有一个受过培训的团队。我们有一个从业者协会。这些人是由我们培训的，他们可以出去做这项工作，并获得许可去做，而且非常了解它。他们已经进行了大量的培训，以获得胜任这项工作的能力，所以他们也可以在那个页面上找到可以帮助他们的人。我想我们协会成员之间现在讲11种语言，所以它是相当全球化的。我已经将这项工作翻译成了大约16种语言，包括刚刚完成的斯瓦希里语，这很酷，因为它是非洲使用人数最多的语言。所以这是一种很容易理解的语言，因为原型是普遍的。
solve it and what would that mean with different options. And there's a team of people who are trained. We have a guild of practitioners. These are people who are trained by us who can go out and do the work and are licensed to do it and know it very well. They've done a lot of training to get, you know, capable to do the work well and so they can find someone on that page as well and who can help them. I think we're speaking 11 languages amongst us now, the guild members, and so it's quite global and it's quite... I've translated the work into about 16 languages at this point, including that just got Swahili, which is kind of cool because it's the most spoken language in Africa. So this is a language that is easily understood because archetypes are universal. It doesn't
无论我们是在和非洲的薯农一起工作（我们确实做过），还是和印度的工程师，或者和美国的专业小团队一起工作，这都完全没有区别。原型是普遍的。每个人都理解它们。每个人都有它们，我们可以激活它们。把原型想象成灵魂的人类基因组。它连接着我们所有人。这是我们共同拥有的东西。无论我们看起来像什么，我们在哪里，我们怎么说话，这都不重要。这是一种灵魂的东西，以我们都能识别的图像出现。就像你刚才说的，我们可以建立骑士、武士和美国大兵之间的联系。
matter if we're working with yam farmers in Africa, which we have, or with, you know, engineers in India or with, you know, a small team of professionals in the United States, it makes absolutely no difference. Archetypes are universal. Everyone understands them. Everyone has them and we can activate them. Think of archetypes as the human genome of the soul. It's that which connects us all. It's what we all have in common. Doesn't matter what we look like, where we are, how we speak. It's a soul thing that appears in images that we all recognize. Like you just said, we can make the connection between a knight
我们可以建立这种联系，因为我们内心有那种原型之眼。你看到，你知道，所谓的创伤或生活事件阻碍了这些东西。听起来在你的一个例子中，你说战士被那种害怕成为施虐者、害怕成为侵略者的恐惧所阻碍。如果我承认我生气，或者激活愤怒，或者变得果断，那么我就会成为伤害我的那个人。你看到过这样的模式吗？然后工作时，绝对是这样。所以每一个原型，这是一个很好的问题，每一个原型都出现在一个量表上。中间是我们所说的“最佳区域”，那是你获得原型天赋的地方。
and a samurai and a, you know, GI. We can make that connection because we have that archetypal eye in us. And you see, you know, what would be called maybe trauma or, you know, life events blocking those things. Like it sounds like in one of your examples, you were saying that the warrior was being blocked by that fear of being the abuser, fear of being the aggressor. If I admit that I'm angry or activate angry or become assertive then I'm gonna be the person who hurt me do you see patterns like that and then work when absolutely so so every archetype it's a great question every archetype appears on a scale in the middle is what we call the optimal zone that's where you get the gifts of
对于战士来说，那就是果断、清晰、能够保护自己、能够为自己挺身而出，你知道，击中目标，拥有目标，诸如此类。这些都是最佳区域中的战士，对某事充满热情，诸如此类。你可以在我们所说的“过度阴影”中过度使用一个原型。
the archetype so for the warrior that will be assertive, clear, able to defend yourself, you know, able to stand up for yourself and fall, you know, hitting a target, being, you know, having a goal, those kinds of things. That's all the warrior in the optimal zone, being fired up about something, those kinds of things. You can overplay an archetype in what we call shadow of too much.
然后战士很快就会变成恶霸、尖叫者、咆哮者或暴力分子，诸如此类。你也可以低估战士，然后人们就会随意践踏你，你无法保护自己，在会议中你显得软弱。所以关键在于识别你在那个“过多”和“过少”的量表上的位置。即使我们非常自在，并且在原型的最佳区域内运作，在糟糕的一天里，我们仍然非常容易过度使用它，我们会翻转并变得过度。或者如果我们无法获取它，我们就会为此付出代价。
And then the warrior quickly becomes a bully and a screamer and a yeller or violent or these kinds of things and you can also underplay the warrior and then people walk all over you and you can't defend yourself and and you know in a meeting you appear weak these kinds of things so so the key is to recognize where you are on that scale of too much and too little and there's almost always you know we have if we're even if we're very comfortable and we're operating in the optimal zone of an archetype it is still very common that on a bad day we'll overplay it and we'll, you know, we'll flip and we'll become too much of it. Or if we don't have access to it, that we pay a price for it, that there's a cost
所以这是一个寻找获取所有原型的学习过程。对我来说，充实的生活和良好的领导力需要对所有10个原型有意识的获取。只要能够在特定情况下知道什么在那里。有人来到人力资源部，你有一个人力资源问题，你需要进入你的“养育者”，去关心、倾听并让对方感到重要。你出去谈新业务，成为你的“讲故事者”和“战士”可能是一件好事，你知道，某种组合。因为现在你可以讲述你的故事，但你很清晰，你领先，你不怕竞争，诸如此类。你试图组织你的业务或你的
to us for not having access to one. So it's a learning process to find access to all the archetypes. A full life to me and good leadership requires access, conscious access to all 10 archetypes. Just being able to, in a certain situation, know what is there. Someone comes into HR, you've got an HR problem, you need to be in your nurturer who cares and listens and makes the other person feel important. You going out for new business, probably a good thing to be in your storyteller and warrior, you know, in that combo of some kind. Because now you can tell tell your story but you're clear and you're ahead and you're you're not afraid of competition and these kind of things you're trying to organize your business or your
仓库一团糟，把一些“战略家”和“战士”结合起来可能很好，因为战略家知道如何组织东西并把它们放在架子上。我从来没见过谁能把他们的10个原型完美地组织起来。所以，或者在最佳区域，我们总是需要学习。总有一些东西处于我们舒适区的底部，有一些处于我们舒适区的顶部。这是一个活生生的东西。我们的个性随生活而改变，但个性的成分不会。但我们如何组合它以及我们对它有多自在，这就是我们拥有代理权的地方。是的，当我做的时候，在我遇到你的工作之前
warehouse is a mess probably good to get some strategists and warrior together because strategist knows how to organize things and put them on shelves i've never met anybody who has all their 10 you know sort of perfectly um organized uh and so 10, you know, sort of perfectly organized. And so, or, you know, in the optimal zone, we're all always have something to learn. There's always something that's at the bottom of our comfort zone and something that's at the top of our comfort zone. And it's an alive thing. Our personality changes over life, but the ingredients of the personality doesn't. But how we put it together and how we're comfortable with it, that's what we have agency over. Yeah, when I was doing, before I encountered your work
几年前，我会做这种躯体和体验式的原型体验，我想让人们在进入某种情况之前，在姿势中感受到战士，你知道，它是如何为他们表现出来的。第一，有没有类似那样的身体感？第二，当我做那种治疗时，我会帮助人们对它们进行分类，如果有人思考得不是特别隐喻或象征性，我会根据动机进行分类，比如，战士的动机是不确定性。它能把球跑多远？它能击败多少人？它能拿到金牌吗？魔术师的动机是拥有确定性。它想要那种确定性，即“我要坐下来弄清楚这个房间里的每个人是怎么想的”。
a couple years back, I would do this somatic and experiential kind of archetypal experience where I wanted people to feel the warrior in their posture, you know, before they went into a certain situation, how it showed up for them. One, you know, is there any kind of physicality like that to it? And then two, another part when I did that type of therapy, I would help people kind of sort them, if somebody didn't think terribly metaphorically or symbolically, you know, I would sort it in terms of motivation and be like, you know, the warrior is motivated by uncertainty. How far can it run the ball? You know, how many people can it defeat? Can it get the gold medal? The magician is, is going to be motivated by, by having certainty. It wants the certainty of, I'm going to sit back and figure out how every single person in this room thinks.
然后我要讲一个让他们都笑的笑话。不仅仅是这些人，我要坐下来弄清楚酒吧里的女孩或老板是怎么想的，我要站起来，以一种在别人看来就像魔法的方式给他们留下深刻印象，因为我想确定我能做到。你有那种东西吗？是的，我喜欢你的思考方式。我喜欢你的思考方式，乔尔。好吧，事情是这样的。是的，“工作中原型”是我和理查德·奥利维尔（Richard Olivier）共同创造的，他当然是劳伦斯·奥利维尔的儿子，有戏剧背景，是一位戏剧导演，他发明了一种叫做“神话剧”（mythodrama）的东西，他用它
And then I'm going to tell a joke that makes all of them laugh. Not just these people, you know, I'm going to sit back and figure out how the girl at the bar or how the boss thinks, and I'm going to stand up and I'm going to impress them in a way that just looks like magic to other people, because I want to be sure that I can do it. Do you have that kind of thing? Yeah, I love how you think. I love how you think, Joel. Well, here's the thing. Yes, Archetypes at Work is co-created between myself and Richard Olivier, who is, of course, the son of Laurence Olivier, comes from a theater background, is a theater director, and he has invented a thing called mythodrama, with which he has done
在世界各地进行了20多年的领导力发展，他的模型基本上是使用莎士比亚作为领导力故事，非常具体化。他让人们在房间里跳来跳去，他们是长期以来世界各地的高管。所以，跳来跳去是半开玩笑的，但是的，所以“工作中原型”也是神话剧式的。换句话说，它是非常非常具体化的。我们不仅有所有原型的姿势，你可以在 archetypesatwork.com/gestures 上看到，它体现了它们并向你展示，你知道，这是一次会议，我真的必须表达我的观点。我知道人们会咄咄逼人地攻击我的想法。我必须成为我的战士。所以他们所做的是，他们走进洗手间，做几次战士姿势，
leadership development for well over 20 years around the world with his models basically using Shakespeare as a leadership story very very much embodied he's had people you know jump around in the room there are very high executives for a long time all around the world and so and jump around the room is you know it's tongue-in-cheek but yes and so Archetypes at Work is also mythodramatic in In other words, it is very, very embodied. And not only do we have gestures for all the archetypes, which you can see at archetypesatwork.com forward slash gestures, which there embodies them and shows you, you know what, this is a meeting, I really have to get my point across. I know people are gonna be aggressively attacking my ideas. I have to be my warrior. And so what they do is they, you know, they go into the bathroom, they do the warrior gesture a couple of times
然后他们走进那个会议，他们充满了活力。你知道，这是一件很棒的事情。我知道有一个人刚刚赢得了一场比赛，作为一名音乐家，她发誓如果她在走上舞台获胜之前没有进入“主权者”状态，她就不会做到这一点。所以，是的，这是一种非常具体化的语言。我们还使用声音、音乐、诗歌和所有其他右脑通道来激活我们内心的这些原型模型。你可以用任何东西玩原型游戏。这是一副眼镜。
and they go into that meeting and they're pumped up. You know, it's a great thing to do. And I know of someone who just won a contest, you know, as a musician who swears that if she hadn't stepped into a sovereign before she stepped out on stage and won, she wouldn't have done so forth. So, yes, it's a very embodied language. We also use sound, music, poetry, all kinds of other right brain accesses to activate these archetypal models in ourselves. You can play the archetypes game with anything. It's a set of glasses.
你可以说，战士地毯会是什么样子？主权者地毯会是什么样子？爱人地毯会是什么样子？等等。或者一块，你知道，或者一些食物。所有这些都是可翻译的。这是一种观察方式。我已经给了你一个爱人食物，巧克力慕斯。也许战士食物是，我不知道，牛排，或者非常辛辣的食物，或者非常热的食物，或者非常火辣的食物之类的。所以当你开始发展这种语言时，你可以玩这些东西，一切都变得非常生动。就像我说的，那是发展“原型之眼”。是的，那真的很有趣。我认为这些力量就在那里，你知道，无论我们是否
You can say, what would a warrior carpet look like? What would a sovereign carpet look like? What would a lover carpet look like? And so on. Or a piece of, you know, or some food. All of it is translatable. It's a way of seeing. I already gave you a, you know, a lover food, the chocolate mousse. Maybe a warrior food is, I don't know a steak or or very spicy food or very hot food or very fiery food or something like that so you can play with these when you start to develop the language everything becomes very much alive like i said that's developing the archetypal eye yeah that's that's really interesting um i i think the forces are there you know whether or not
识别它们。很多时候，这从来不是真正的临床心理学家。总是有人刚上了他们的第一门心理学研究入门课，就给我发邮件说我不应该拥有执照，因为他们谷歌搜索了一些东西并上了播客。但我认为，你知道，当大脑中形成楔前叶的那一刻，所有这些信息都在那里被处理，但我们还没有感知到它。然后当楔前叶的那个小种子在一百万年后形成时，你就有了维伦多夫的维纳斯，因为，你知道，
we recognize them. A lot of times it's never an actual clinical psychologist. It's always somebody who's just taken their first psych research one-on-one class that sends me an email and says I shouldn't have a license because they Google something and get on the podcast. But I think like, you know, that moment that the precuneus forms in the brain, you know, all this information is there being processed, you know, but we're not perceiving it yet. And then when the precunious is the little seed of that is formed a million years later, you have the Venus of Willendorf because, you know,
我们认出了它们。很多时候，这从来不是真正的临床心理学家。总是一些刚上完心理学研究入门课的人给我发邮件，说我不应该拥有执照，因为他们谷歌搜索了一些东西，然后就上了播客。但我认为，你知道，当楔前叶在大脑中形成的那一刻，所有这些信息都在那里被处理，但我们还没有感知到它。然后，当楔前叶的种子在一百万年后形成时，你就有了维伦多夫的维纳斯，因为，你知道，
perceiving ourselves becomes hard. You know, when we're unconsciously just processing the information, there's such a difference in those things. You know, it's, it's a birth of something. And the people that send me that email, I write back and I say, like, you know, you don't have to notice any of this stuff. You can go your whole life and not notice it. But, you know, somehow if somebody on LinkedIn or something, you know, when you see all this subjectivity and intuition, it's such a waste to not engage with it because you see this subjectivity and intuition and transcendental function and symbolic thinking get projected onto these other things. Like the person that says anything but CBT isn't evidence-based and you have to do therapy like a formula and there's a manualizable form of it. We could let an AI do it. When you look at that person's Facebook page, you see conspiracy theories and wild religiosity after they tell you how to practice therapy. Exactly. I would like to know how, what this person is so afraid of. I would be quite compassionate and say, what are you so afraid of? Why is it such a threat to your thinking that
感知自我变得很困难。你知道，当我们无意识地处理信息时，这两者之间存在着巨大的差异。你知道，这是一种事物的诞生。那些给我发邮件的人，我会回复他们说，你知道，你不必注意到所有这些东西。你可以过完一生而不去注意它。但是，你知道，如果 LinkedIn 上有人或者其他什么人，当你看到所有这些主观性和直觉时，不去参与其中简直是一种浪费，因为你会看到这种主观性、直觉、超越功能和象征性思维被投射到其他事物上。就像那些说除了 CBT（认知行为疗法）之外的一切都不是循证的，你必须像套用公式一样进行治疗，并且有一种可以手册化的形式。我们可以让 AI 来做。当你查看那个人的 Facebook 页面时，你会发现他们在告诉你如何进行治疗之后，却充斥着阴谋论和狂热的宗教信仰。确实如此。我想知道这个人到底在害怕什么。我会非常富有同情心地说，你在害怕什么？为什么别人的想法对你的思维构成如此大的威胁？
somebody thinks differently? Or why is it such a threat to your thinking? Not trying to convince them that the way you and I think is better, but just why is it such a threat that things that aren't measurable are real to some people why is that so difficult it's the same thing with religion for some people religion is incredibly incredibly real so why should we tell them that they're nuts or that that's wrong or that it's you know it's a belief system it's a way of thinking it's a way of seeing the world it's it's just just because it's not measurable doesn't make it real to someone who's religious religion is very very real and so um you know and and everything is infused by it in the way they see everything
别人有不同的想法？或者为什么这对你的思维构成如此大的威胁？我不是想说服他们你我的想法更好，只是为什么那些不可衡量的事物对某些人来说是真实的，这会构成如此大的威胁？为什么这那么难以接受？宗教也是一样，对某些人来说，宗教是极其极其真实的，所以我们为什么要告诉他们他们疯了，或者那是错的，或者你知道，那是一个信仰体系，这是一种思维方式，这是一种看待世界的方式，仅仅因为它不可衡量，并不意味着对于一个有宗教信仰的人来说它就不真实，宗教是非常非常真实的，所以嗯，你知道，而且一切都以他们看待事物的方式融入其中。
it's a way of seeing it's perfectly okay with me and there's lots of different ways but to claim that it's the only way of seeing or that every other way of seeing including other religions is wrong that's where the problem is because that's not recognizing that you're in a tree but that becomes absolutism. Anybody who has the truth, be the truth, be CBT, or be the truth, be a religion, sorry, but nobody holds the key to truth. There's no such thing.
这是一种看待事物的方式，我完全可以接受，而且有很多不同的方式，但声称这是唯一的看待方式，或者声称所有其他看待方式（包括其他宗教）都是错误的，这就是问题所在，因为那没有意识到你身处树林之中，但这变成了绝对主义。任何声称拥有真理的人，无论是 CBT，还是某种宗教，抱歉，但没有人掌握真理的钥匙。根本没有那种东西。
And it doesn't mean everything is relative. It means that there are objective ways to distinguish what different people believe has its own place, that's all. Different trees are different mindsets. I mean, it goes all the way back to Aristotle and Plato, you know, to those conversations that, you know, between left brain and right brain, it goes right there. And having to pick a side, I think, is a mistake. What if we could have both in our brain? Wouldn't that be way cooler? And that's totally possible because we're all wired that way.
这并不意味着一切都是相对的。这意味着有一些客观的方法来区分不同人所相信的事物，它们各有各的位置，仅此而已。不同的树代表不同的思维模式。我的意思是，这可以一直追溯到亚里士多德和柏拉图，你知道，追溯到左脑和右脑之间的那些对话，就在那里。我认为必须选边站是一个错误。如果我们的大脑能两者兼备会怎样？那不是更酷吗？这完全是有可能的，因为我们的大脑天生就是这样连接的。
Yeah, the two schools of thought, you know, the academy and, you know, that. And I think when you look at the relationship that we have, like one of the things that's scary about what you're doing or what Jung's doing or any kind of depth work is you're telling people that philosophy and anthropology and psychology have to be the same discipline in a way where people who are afraid of a part of themselves are going to say, no, you can't bring that into it. But in the same way that you can get a philosopher who's overly logical to tell on themselves, you can do that with psychology. You can look at a model of therapy and say,
是的，这两个思想流派，你知道，学院派和那个。我认为当你审视我们之间的关系时，比如你所做的，或者荣格所做的，或者任何形式的深度工作，其中可怕的一点是，你在告诉人们哲学、人类学和心理学必须成为同一门学科，而那些害怕自己内心某一部分的人会说，不，你不能把它带进来。但就像你可以让一个过于逻辑化的哲学家自曝其短一样，你也可以对心理学这样做。你可以审视一种治疗模型并说，
what are you afraid of based on how they define the self? And in something like you do, it's very open-ended. You're not pretending to know the person is engaging with the self that is, you're not in control of, you know, something like CBT is limiting the self down to cognition and behavior, which to me is something that, and they would say that, well, if you follow it, it goes down to belief, but look at those beliefs. They're not terribly deep. You know, that's a step in the wrong direction. Literally not deep. Right. But something like ABA that says you're only other people's ability to perceive your behavior, that is terrifying.
根据他们如何定义自我，你在害怕什么？在你所做的事情中，它是非常开放的。你并没有假装知道这个人正在与你无法控制的自我互动，你知道，像 CBT 这样的东西将自我限制在认知和行为上，对我来说，这是某种……他们会说，好吧，如果你遵循它，它会归结为信念，但看看那些信念。它们并不怎么深刻。你知道，那是朝着错误方向迈出的一步。字面上说并不深刻。没错。但像 ABA（应用行为分析）那样说你只是别人感知你行为的能力，那太可怕了。
I mean, applied behavior analysis is so scary because it's saying there is no self. You are only what other people see. That's worse than cognitive therapy. Yeah. Yeah. And the problem is that right now, i think things are going to shift and the fastest growing school of psychology that you can't even get into right now i've been told is is internal family systems a multiple model that's very hot right now so these things come and go right now the behaviorists and
我的意思是，应用行为分析太可怕了，因为它说根本没有自我。你只是别人所看到的样子。那比认知疗法更糟。是的。是的。问题在于，现在我认为情况将会发生转变，我被告知目前增长最快的心理学流派是内在家庭系统（IFS），这是一种目前非常热门的多重模型，所以这些东西来来去去，现在行为主义者和
cbt has pretty much dominated the insurance industry and what people get paid for and and what is real and what is acceptable and what is therapy that's fine there's always going to be those of us who aren't in that model and that number is growing there's now other things like eco psychology and and and embodied psychology and all these kinds of things and of of course, archetypal psychology has become huge. There's a whole new way of thinking that, as the world changes and the values change in the world and that left brain thinking just isn't enough anymore,
CBT 几乎统治了保险业，以及人们为之付费的内容，什么是真实的，什么是可接受的，什么是治疗，这没关系。总会有我们这些不在那个模型中的人，而且这个数字正在增长。现在还有其他东西，比如生态心理学、具身心理学以及所有这些东西，当然，原型心理学已经变得非常庞大。随着世界的变化和世界价值观的改变，那种左脑思维已经不再足够了，有一种全新的思维方式，
the need for something more is going to come really quickly. And so I have a classic psych 101 book that's an inch and a half thick. It has a quarter page of jung and freud's or as a side note as sort of a mistake yeah these guys existed too they believed in this deep stuff and things like dreams i mean can you believe it you know kind of like that i mean that i find that sad i find that sad and my nephew has a classic psych degree from somewhere and he doesn't practice it in any way but i remember
对更多东西的需求将会很快到来。所以我有一本经典的心理学 101 书，有一英寸半厚。它只有四分之一页是关于荣格和弗洛伊德的，或者作为一个侧注，就像一个错误，是的，这些家伙也存在，他们相信这些深层的东西，还有像梦这样的东西，我的意思是你能相信吗，你知道，有点像那样，我的意思是，我觉得这很可悲，我觉得这很可悲，我的侄子从某个地方获得了经典的心理学学位，他并没有以任何方式实践它，但我记得
when he was in school what he was telling me what he was doing it was just like i just thought it was that it's so left-brain and it's so it's all biology based and it's just it's fun to do that it's science but don't call it psychology it's biology and it's weeding out everybody who isn't um beneficial to the market by applying that kind of reductivism to psychology yeah exactly and you know psychology has the word psyche in it which means soul there's not a lot of soul in most cbt in fact there's none so you know i it's not for me it worked for some people it's great you know for certain things you know if i have ocd probably probably um uh you know uh cbt is pretty useful. However, I've had some pretty good results working with OCD people as well by understanding the archetypal pattern and finding a different way to do it.
当他在学校时，他告诉我在做什么，我只是觉得它太左脑了，而且完全基于生物学，做那个很有趣，那是科学，但不要称之为心理学，那是生物学，它通过将那种还原论应用于心理学，淘汰了所有对市场没有益处的人。是的，完全正确。而且你知道心理学这个词里有“psyche”，意思是灵魂。大多数 CBT 中没有多少灵魂，事实上，根本没有。所以你知道，它不适合我，它对某些人有效，这很好，你知道，对于某些事情，你知道，如果我有强迫症，可能，可能，嗯，你知道，CBT 还是很有用的。然而，我在与强迫症患者合作时也取得了一些相当不错的结果，通过理解原型模式并找到一种不同的方法来做到这一点。
Wow, what a revolutionary thought that actually works. So to me, in the end, the only thing that matters is how things work. To me, I like to see usefulness.ness again we're back where we started if it's not practical if it's not useful if it's just based on the theory i don't care about it but i've had more people tell me that you know one hour of getting an astrological reading has changed their life you know and they've been in therapy for 30 years and they never got to the same depth i've had people tell me that many many many many times probably literally hundreds of times so then i think there's some value to what i'm doing i'm not saying the therapy is wrong i'm not a therapist but what i do is do sort of the x-ray and then work with a therapist
哇，这是一个多么革命性的想法，而且确实有效。所以对我来说，最终，唯一重要的是事情如何运作。对我来说，我喜欢看到实用性。再次回到我们开始的地方，如果它不实用，如果它没有用，如果它只是基于理论，我不在乎它。但我有更多的人告诉我，你知道，进行一小时的占星解读改变了他们的生活，你知道，他们已经接受了 30 年的治疗，却从未达到同样的深度。我听过很多人这样说，很多很多次，可能字面上几百次了，所以我认为我所做的事情是有价值的。我不是说治疗是错误的，我不是治疗师，但我所做的是进行某种 X 光检查，然后与治疗师合作。
i think i have 19 psychiatrists in my clients i checked that the other day for something else so people who are therapists and i can't think about how many therapists I have as clients so people who understand the value of of getting insights and then working with them and so I think what an astrologer can do is give the insights to the therapist like you said and then therapist does the therapy work there's nothing wrong with that but those insights can you know shave six months off of therapy and can say and can you don't need to know the past you don't need to know the history of the person when you have an astrology chart you can see all of it right there and it's a very powerful tool it's just a tool but it's a useful tool to me if you're a medical doctor someone walks in with a broken arm you're a country doctor
我想我的客户中有 19 位精神科医生，我前几天为了别的事情查过。所以那些是治疗师的人，我数不清我有多少治疗师作为客户。所以那些理解获得洞察力然后与他们合作的价值的人，所以我认为占星师可以做的是像你所说的那样为治疗师提供洞察力，然后治疗师进行治疗工作，这没什么错。但这些洞察力可以，你知道，缩短六个月的治疗时间，并且可以说，你不需要了解过去，当你拥有占星图时，你不需要了解这个人的历史，你可以直接看到所有这些，这是一个非常强大的工具。它只是一个工具，但对我来说是一个有用的工具。如果你是一名医生，有人手臂骨折走进来，你是一名乡村医生，
and you say yeah i think i can set it pretty well and then we'll put a cast on it it'll grow back straight yeah that's probably pretty good but imagine how much better you would do with an x-ray so we provide the x-rays astrologers the therapist still then has a much better way of setting the arm and you know and setting it straight so yeah i think that's that's the that's the gift it's understanding people's place and it's not disrespecting people who think differently I think that's the main message from today you know just because someone does something you don't understand or think is weird or think is difficult or think is or think is you
你说，是的，我想我可以把它接得很好，然后我们会给它打上石膏，它会长得笔直，是的，那可能相当不错，但想象一下如果你有 X 光片会做得好多少。所以我们提供 X 光片，占星师，治疗师然后就有了一种更好的方式来接骨，你知道，并把它接直。所以是的，我认为这就是天赋，这是理解人们的位置，而不是不尊重那些想法不同的人。我认为这是今天的主要信息，你知道，仅仅因为某人做了一些你不理解、认为奇怪、认为困难或认为，或认为你
know doesn't match your model of reality doesn't make it wrong and you know tolerance is a nice thing is just to say i'm curious tell me more about it then i'll make a decision once i've actually studied it you i've studied it you've not kind of a thing like newton said that's powerful well that's that's beautiful i don't want to be respectful of your time we'll definitely link to your website and where people can reach out and get more information on either being trained or receiving help. You know, if they are a leader, if they do have one of these companies, are there any books or other services you want to point people to? All of that is on the websites. And so I just, I want, you know, I don't want to have a website
知道，不符合你的现实模型，并不意味着它是错的。你知道，宽容是一件好事，只是说我很好奇，多告诉我一些，然后等我真正研究过之后再做决定。你研究过，而你没有，就是那种情况。就像牛顿所说的那样，这很有力量。嗯，那很美。我不想占用你太多时间，我们一定会链接到你的网站，以及人们可以在哪里联系并获得更多关于接受培训或获得帮助的信息。你知道，如果他们是领导者，如果他们确实拥有这些公司之一，有什么书籍或其他服务你想向人们推荐吗？所有这些都在网站上。所以我只是，我想要，你知道，我不想有一个网站，
where people, to me, this kind of work is very personal. So yeah, a lot of information is on the websites and that's lovely. But to me, if someone really wants to talk deeper about something or really talk about a problem they're having at work, let's talk, let's have a conversation. And then I can show them how the archetypal model could help them, you know, solve some of these very common issues that they're not the only ones who have but it's a novel approach that is to me much more efficient and effective and people love it because it is so fun it's like wow I've been seen I've been looked at properly somebody cares about me enough to to you know do this assessment with me and and now look about look at look at how my
人们，对我来说，这种工作是非常私人的。所以是的，网站上有很多信息，这很好。但对我来说，如果有人真的想更深入地谈论某事，或者真的谈论他们在工作中遇到的问题，让我们谈谈，让我们进行一次对话。然后我可以向他们展示原型模型如何帮助他们，你知道，解决一些他们并不是唯一遇到这些非常常见的问题，但这是一种新颖的方法，对我来说效率更高、效果更好，人们喜欢它，因为它太有趣了，就像哇，我被看见了，我被正确地审视了，有人足够关心我，你知道，和我一起做这个评估，现在看看，看看我的
relationship has changed. I know tons of stories of people who didn't talk for years in a company and now they do because they have this archetypal language. There's so many different ways you can apply this. It's a really useful tool. It's just a tool, but it is a very useful tool. Like one of those multi-tools, you know,
关系发生了怎样的变化。我知道很多公司里多年不说话的人的故事，现在他们说话了，因为他们有了这种原型语言。你可以用很多不同的方式来应用它。这是一个非常有用的工具。它只是一个工具，但它是一个非常有用的工具。就像那些多功能工具一样，你知道，
you can use for, that has everything on it. Well, that's beautiful.'s a that's a wonderful uh intro to your work and i hope that this connects you with some people who want to learn more about those things so um we can leave it there and i will link to all of these things below but we move like roman soldiers into the wilds of the psyche to fix under cancelling star hermes and Aphrodite There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以用它来做任何事情，它上面什么都有。嗯，那很美。这是对你工作的精彩介绍，我希望这能让你与一些想更多了解这些事情的人建立联系。所以，嗯，我们可以到此为止，我会在下面链接所有这些东西，但我们像罗马士兵一样进入心灵的荒野，在赫尔墨斯和阿佛洛狄忒的星辰下进行修复。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。